nice to see everyone here today
we will open up our executive session on
House Bill 288 relative to taxation of
sole proprietorship businesses the chair
recognizes representative fellows for a
motion thank you madam chair I'd like to
move itl on this bill
representative Southworth seconds the
motion of itl is it would you like to
speak to your motion yes
um so what this bill does is it exempts
proprietor trip ships which are single
person owned business and also single
person limited liability corporations
from both the business profits and the
business Enterprise tax
and what we heard from revenue
Administration is they estimated that
the loss once we get a couple years out
would be about 36 million annually if we
were to do this
and they also indicated that they
thought that this could be exempting
just a certain
class
of people being taxed
or you know of the of the business is to
exempt a certain type
um a certain type based on the ownership
would probably be inconse
unconstitutional and you know they
couldn't say before because you know
they're dra but they recommended that it
should go we should get an opinion from
Department of Justice before we would
move forward with anything like this
thank you
other comments
oh representative jinnegan
thank you madam chair
um yes there's also um
just a fairness issue with this as well
um there's when you look at the
situation you can have a two-person LLC
that effectively May gross and net less
than a one member LLC and yet the one
member LLC doesn't pay taxes and the two
member or or larger does and and I'm
also aware of examples of people who
have proprietorships that are fairly
good sized and bigger than many two
person and three-person Etc LLCs and to
exempt them and and not you know you're
going to have a fairness issue as well
thank you
where was it involving
um I had raised this issue with the
um
Mr Wong but I'm
actually there's an email I haven't read
from him yet he may have answered it but
uh he calculated the BET loss but like
like representative janigan I have know
of some people that one person that had
who's a hedge fund owner
and has the rest of his business in New
York on who I don't know if he is an LLC
or not but if he is he's certainly
and I should probably mention for the
record I do pay bet and BBT so this
would impact me but
other comments anyway yes representative
Spielberg
thank you madam chair I think one of the
arguments in favor of this bill that was
raised
is that an LLC is a pass-through entity
for federal income tax purposes
but in that case it passes through to
the individual who then files a federal
income tax return and Pays His tax
accordingly
in the state of New Hampshire where we
have no income tax
that analogy does not follow
and passing the bill would result in no
tax whatsoever on this business income
representative putt
yes I just wanted to apologize for the
uh author of this bill Travis Corcoran
he didn't show up for hearing when we
were hearing it he didn't know about it
his his uh email was screwed up with the
clerk's office so he didn't get notice
on by five different bills so he does
apologize I told him what the likely
outcome was going to be he sits next to
more discussion
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
the motion on the table is itl on House
Bill 288.
yes
representative Ellery
representative dissette
yes representative spilsbury yes
representative votes yes uh
representative naughter yes
representative sodi
yes representative ores
represent Rochford yes represent almi
yes representative Ames yes we're up in
the Southworth yes representative Malloy
yes reperto Schaumburg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger
yes
representative leapley
representative Smith
yes and the chair
yes the devote is 20 in favor of itl
zero opposed and uh would everyone be
comfortable with this being put on the
consent calendar
any
conversation on that representative
Mueller
I'm sorry yeah
that's what he said
yeah uh the question is because it has a
fiscal note uh can it be on the consent
calendar so probably not yeah that's
okay okay great
um and I forgot to uh welcome
representative Nutter thank you for
being here today
what you think your committee's more
riveting than ours what committee would
that be we got Iron Works down the hall
Committee of nerds and Geeks come and
visit us sometimes in Science and Tech
okay with that we'll close the is there
going to be emotional excuse me a
speaker or not
uh we'll
determine that later Pro I assume
there's going to be no debate but
obviously if you made the motion always
be prepared to
yes
20-0 itl so we'll close the executive
okay I'm actually I'm going to recognize
our researcher Jennifer four who just
whispered in my ear some great
information Jennifer would you explain
it's my understanding that you can't
pass
um that sort of Bill on consent but you
Madam chair yes question representative
Sherwood
oh yes she said uh if the on the consent
calendar was 20 to 0 ought to pass we
would need to have it on the regular
calendar we couldn't put on the consent
calendar because it's an itl motion
we will attempt to do that but it will
be up to the house Clerk to decide that
well Market is consent
um because it was an itl motion and
assume that but in all cases be prepared
to speak if someone has a question on
the floor if it gets pulled from consent
we never know what's going to happen
Okay okay with that we will now open the
executive session on 297 and the chair
recognizes representative all me
thank you madam chair I move on
ought to pass on oh out to pass with
Amendment
on
to HB 297 the dedicated funds review
do you want to present your amendment to
us now uh is there a second yeah we
should say the second is there a second
on ought to pass with Amendment
representative elberger seconds to
motion could you speak to your motion
on
yes
not very well at this point
um but on this
on
is a relatively a housekeeping measure
this year on the dedicated funds we are
repealing to on
on dedicated funds which have no money
in them and no prospects
of having money in them
um
and
on we also removed from
consideration
on
five I think it is on funds which are on
Enterprise funds of the state in one
form or another and therefore report in
Fallen are audited in full outside of
the dedicated funds committee so we
actually do not get the financial
information we need to review them
so that's um oh and the amendment I need
to to request that we pass the amendment
on which has been passed out now to
everybody
um that is
on
rework rewording both of the two repeals
um
because we had on not remembered to
include the second on section of each
which
would stay have stayed in the the law as
uh establishing funds that will no
longer exist the room and board
scholarship fund uh was set up with
great Intentions by some members a
number of years ago to provide for the
Orphans of fire and police that were
killed in the line of duty but the
University was already doing that
and declined to move it to a separate
place and so nobody told people that
they could donate to that fund
and uh it has no money in it and it has
never been been used
um the Cold Case unit fund
was also set up with the ideas that
people would donate to a fund which
could help support the one person in the
Cold Case unit who is doing Muhammad
homicide work and the gentleman retired
a year and a half ago actually but in
the history of the fund which I think is
about eight years they've had one 100
donation because nobody really knows
about it and I don't know how many cold
cases actually get solved that they they
have a family that cares a lot about it
at the time it happens but there were is
only one hundred dollars which the uh in
the fund and we had quite a long
conversation about that and the
department of
uh safety is going on oh no of justice
is going to be figuring out where to put
to put the hundred dollars as a cost of
the Cold Case unit and spend it and then
send a letter back to the family
thanking them again
uh
before we close the fund we've given
them until January I believe next year
and they said they can do that
so that's the kind of minutia that we
deal with sometimes it's
a lot more complicated and than that but
this last year was pretty easy
all the discussion I think I see
representative Oliver's hand uh
representative Army take this question
yes it's my understanding that any
dedicated fund automatically goes in is
reviewed by these this fund unless
excluded or does it have to be
statutorily included on
when we started out
and we started out saying that they all
had to be included on I
I got the new Vice chair of the
committee to work with me on it the
first time and he suggested a hammer
which we put in which said if
we have if we find you and and you
haven't uh registered in 612 within six
months then your money is getting taken
away
which of course we couldn't quite do in
some cases but you're going too far
[Laughter]
I don't think it's ever been done but it
did get people's attention uh but on
there are a number of dedicated funds
which like
Seabrook for instance which we took off
the books all together early on but the
new comptroller said okay you need to
leave these in
uh the the University of New Hampshire
uh fund even though the money goes into
it and goes out of it so quickly that we
don't
that it's not registered anywhere
um and the liquor fund
and
and uh
no they they these are all separately
audited apparently in the kafir process
I believe it is on they are separately
audited and they are separately reported
thank you madam chair I just wish to
make that clear for the committee
because we're dealing with some
dedicated funds for a group along on the
year
and I did want to make it clear to the
committee when we get a dedicated fund
that
that somebody wants to establish which
they're going to be funded with
donations
we need to cut
ask them about their game plan for
getting the donation so we don't have to
any other discussion representative yes
thank you madam chair this is a question
for representative Almy I'm I'm looking
at the the amendment and I'm looking at
the and maybe I'm not understanding what
the amendment does because I
the the copy of the bill that I had
originally I I don't see the difference
between the amendment and what we have
originally in the bill
it looks like we've have those repealing
that those those things are repealed in
maybe and I could be wrong
um they are repealed uh what chain well
two things that changed one is that on
you have
Roman one but we did not
remove Roman 2.
and I'm doing all of this without
the original wording is on the second
page line seven second page line 17 to
20. uh and it repeals uh the first one
repeals uh 612 1B 278.
it does not
repeal
187 a20a 2B which is established in the
room and board scholarship fund
that would have still remained in the
law and somebody someday might have
picked it up and said what is this and
why
on and the same thing
oh and that one also on somebody had a
hiccup and in on line 17 it says
relative to relative to monies and I
forget who picked that one up but we got
rid of that part of it
um
and on five
on it also repeals the 612
and does not repeal the cold cased
so line 10 in the amendment is new and
Line 6 in the amendment is new
and line four is corrected for the
hiccup
so whenever there's an amendment like
that sometimes have to restructure it a
little bit
to make it appear proper
yeah
we we do sometimes find that the same
language is crept into some other
uh
part of the law too and it's better to
just do a word search and try to find it
but
okay seeing none the clerk will first
call the role on the amendment which is
2023.0237h
thank you madam chair
uh representative and this time I got
the name without stumbling perfect yes
uh representative ulery yes
representative Doucette yes
representative spilsbury yes
representative Plattsburgh CS
representative notter yes representative
Saudi yes representative orrs yes
representative yes representative of all
me yes represent Ames yes representative
Southworth yes representative Malloy yes
representative Schomburg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative liply yes
uh representative Smith yes and Madam
chair
yes road is 20 to zero to pass the
amendment adopt the amendment
thank you and now the motion before us
is ought to pass as amended on House
Bill 297 and the clerk will call the
rule in a second I shall
take your time
let's see that was moved by uh
representative Al me and seconded by
and I keep all my paperwork straight
okay
um and uh same with the uh the main
motion
you know we should probably have a
second motion on on the ought to pass as
amended uh so would you like to move
that
thank you and I move ought to pass on on
House Bill 297 as amended by at the
moment Amendment 237 h
and uh is there a second representative
okay uh representative janigian yes
representative Valerie yes
representative set yes representative
yes representative uh plant votes yes
representative uh Nader yes
representative sodi yes representative
orrs yes representative Rochford yes
represent all me yes
representative Ames yes representative
Southworth yes representative Malloy yes
representative Schomberg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative leapley yes
representative Smith yes and the Madam
chair
yes 20 to zero it's an adoption the vote
being 20-0 of ought to pass is amended
uh we will attempt to put this on the
consent calendar unless there's any
discussion about that okay we will put
it on the consent calendar
Madam chair yes there's one thing I'd
like to to tell a committee about
um related to this but other things that
we may get in the future uh when a
member brings in an amendment
on then
on and only the members can bring in
amendments but you can bring in an
amendment for the sponsor or somebody
else on they the we just passed the
amendment is 237 H the clerk's office is
going to turn that into the committee
Amendment and it will have a different
number
at that point we have to be a little
careful about did they get the numbers
wrong in the calendar because that's
okay we will now close the hearing on
House Bill 297 excuse me the executive
session and we will now open the
executive session on House Bill 569.
and recognize representative Ames for a
motion
I move I move retention on the house
bill
representative elberger seconds would
you like to speak to your motion yes and
thank you
so this is a bill that uh might be
thought of in three different parts one
is to
change the way the taxes
collected and deposited
and the second is uh relates to the low
and moderate homeowners property tax
relief program and the third is a study
related to uh property tax that's
embedded in rent payments and so on the
first part of the
uh which is often
if it's a component of the law that's
often referred to as swept retention
this bill would instead of allowing for
retention of excess swept I should have
said excess swept retention uh it would
require that all swept proceeds net of a
three percent
uh collection allowance for the
municipalities would be remitted to the
state and from the state would flow out
according to whatever formulas were then
in place
to presumably School purposes but it
could be broader than that depending on
how over the years it gets characterized
so it'd be all money flowing into the
state net of three percent that's one
component of it and the second component
is the tax relief program and this bill
would change some of the numbers in that
in that and also provide relief from the
school tax as well as the swept tax
and then the third element speaks for
itself it would be simply a study of uh
of the issue of uh property tax viewed
more broadly to include
um its payment through through rent
payments in effect
so why retain it uh the uh the reason
really is that
um we we talked about it when I
presented the bill that there is
litigation going on it's very
interesting litigation and it's uh it's
reaching its uh
hope it appears to be you always have to
put in a qualifier there reaching the
end
um there is a motion for a partial
summary judgment that was filed uh
towards the end of last year it's uh
being hotly litigated and um
the plaintiffs have filed their brief
the state has filed its repo its
response its opposition uh an
intervening entity called the uh
oh
I can't remember the name it's a group
of of municipalities
um and sympathetic municipalities that
um that pay act that retain the excess
swept so they used to be called donor
communities
um concerned Coalition of concerned
communities or something like that is a
different name is that it I can't
remember
Coalition is for short yeah
uh maybe something like that so uh the
Coalition has filed a brief too those
are in the Court's hands and now the
state of the United State the plaintiffs
get a chance to file a reply brief to
all that that's due at the towards the
end of this month the last week of this
month
uh so very soon and then
the uh State and the uh these uh this
Coalition get to reply reply to the
reply and that's a week later so all the
briefing will be done by uh early early
March and then it's in the hands of the
Court
um it's a pretty focused issue I
wouldn't be surprised to see the court
proceed on it and issue a decision
fairly promptly as judge grew off but he
doesn't seem to be the kind of Judge
that sits on things
um
so uh that's a big deal and the
arguments in there are interesting I
just
will say that from the state from the
plaintiff side it's a tax issue and
um the allowance uh to
so-called excess or high property
value towns to retain uh revenues that
are collected at this wept the Statewide
education property tax rate above
that communities adequacy amount is an
allowance that effectively Returns the
money into the pockets of the taxpayers
of that Community resulting in a
disproportionate tax
that can be said more artfully but
basically it's a a argument based on the
tax clause in the Constitution which is
strictly interpreted there's not much
deference given to communities if you
you're either in or you're out
um the argument that the state is
putting back to that is say no it's not
a tax issue the money is collected
there's a there's a uniform rate across
the state
it's received and what the state does
with it then
becomes a spending issue
so we switch over from
from the tax Clause of the Constitution
to spending clause
when it comes to spending the state has
uh traditionally been given a lot of
leeway by the court to spend
you know to make up make its policy and
make decisions according to that policy
and the the court is unlikely to step
into that so that's that's the argument
that's been Advanced by uh the
respondents the state and the concerned
communities and
and its novel is new to uh to this case
anyway it was not raised in the several
cases in which this issue was raised
back in the early 2000s
um and uh we'll see uh and I I just
wanted to share with you it's
interesting The Briefing is interesting
and uh
there's no point in going forward with
this bill at this time given that this
part of the bill may be
significantly affected by at least the
Superior Court decision remembering that
all was Superior Court decisions can be
appealed further but that's where we
stand that's why I'd like to retain it
beyond that I I feel the need to look
closely at some of the numbers in the
calculation of the refunds for taxpayers
so that other section needs some work
we'll use the time to do that work so
that's it
any other discussion representative
balmy
thank you on during the hearing on Mr
Wong said that we would uh that he
really didn't know much about
the municipal part of the dra and
couldn't comment on how this bill works
I think it would be useful if this
becomes a hot issue to bring in the
municipal part of the dra and get them
to explain how that interacts with the
Statewide property tax
other discussion
seeing none the clerk will call the role
and the motion before us is retain House
yes representative Valerie yes
representative set yes representative
spilsbury yes representative pled votes
yes representative naughter yes
representative Saudi yes representative
orrs yes representative yes
representative army yes representative
Ames yes representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
Schaumburg yes representative fellows
yes representative Bolton yes
representative elberger yes
representative liply yes representative
Smith yes and Madam chair yes voters
20-0 in favor of retention excellent uh
so we will retain motion passes we will
close the public healing on five the
executive session on 569 and I will ask
the members uh not on the retained
motion because that's retained in the
committee but on the other two if you
could have your uh what do we call it
now we don't call it a blurb the report
the committee report done preferably by
one today so that we can get it to our
committee assistant so that we could get
it in the calendar
yes okay great so if you could work
toward that that would be great
now
okay we're not too far off
we will now we ready to thank you for
joining us
we will now open up the uh public are
you ready representative Ames this is
and
foreign
okay are you ready for me
you know what we could use a pink card
from you at some point
but we will now open up the public
hearing on House Bill 220 and recognize
representative Ames who is the Prime
sponsor and who will do a pink card
okay and if I appear a bit frazzled is
because uh like all the rest of you I am
um
well uh this bill
is a bill to I don't seem to find a copy
okay
all right here we go
um
House Bill 220
is a bill that I filed
um
uh largely because representative brahmi
who had led the effort that this bill
um relates to
uh as we all know was not re-elected and
I felt that important to get this going
I have been working with him and he
would have done this uh
but he's not here to do it um so the
committee establishes
uh or you one might say continues a
committee to study the regulatory
structure of charitable gaming
and you have and what I've handed out
the main part of the report of this
committee from
last year
dated November 1 2022
um
uh Senator
D'Alessandro chaired this effort I was a
totally bipartisan commission
and uh
also on the committee was Senator gaida
and then
representative Doucette was there as
well
um so we we uh we worked as much as we
were able given covet and other
distractions
um but in truth as
as we neared the summertime Senator
Guida had decided not to continue in
office and uh with Drew from the
committee in effect
um and um
uh then uh I think there was one other
issue but I'm not remembering it but in
any event we we visited a number of the
sites where charitable Gaming's
occurring and uh and met and talked
about the issues and uh determined at
the end that we really needed to have
this effort continue and
at the end I just want to read this
the committee recommends filing
legislation to continue the efforts of
the study
the landscape of gaming in the state is
highly complex ever-changing and growing
at a significant rate by continuing this
study members will be able to move
forward in delving into the multifaceted
challenges faced by the game operators
the New Hampshire Lottery Commission and
the Charities involved the charge of the
committee would remain the same allowing
the members to build off of the work
already completed over the course of the
past two years I passed out a news
article
um it was actually from a New Hampshire
public radio that I thought was pretty
good and it just is uh out off the press
so to speak February 14th
and in here it uh
down in the fourth paragraph
talks about the brook that was one of
the casinos that we visited it is an
impressive place
well-round well-managed and
um
you know full of interesting things
and there's this statement and I think
this is why we need to study this uh the
the book is a stark symbol of New
Hampshire's Embrace over the past decade
of a wide range of gambling options a
suite of offerings that would have been
all but unimaginable just a few years
ago
though a bill to legalize casinos never
passed in the state house I should say
parenthetically that I was deeply
involved in that with that bill I was
the chair of the gambling commission
that was set up I think was during
Governor Hassan's time and uh this bill
followed from the work of that
commission and it got awfully closed I
think it was a one vote margin
but it did not pass maybe that's just as
well who knows but though a bill to
legalize casinos never passed in the
State House so-called charitable Gaming
facilities have proliferated and evolved
into exact replicas of casinos complete
with craps games complicated carpet
pattern patterns and rows of slot
machines the state has legalized other
forms of gambling in recent years both
online and in person
should say that that reference to slot
machines is this reporter's way of
describing those machines their stock
gaming machines there has been a lot of
debate in this committee as to whether
they're slot machines or some other kind
of machine
and I don't want to get into that debate
but this is this is the new new world
that's out there I think it's a good
idea
uh
foreign
so uh this is the New World
um and I think it uh it prudent for this
committee which uh has the
responsibility
taken from the house to Monitor and act
on all gaming bills uh to
um
understand fully what's going on
um and a premier concern
um it's not I don't want to overstate
this uh Premier
aspect of the over overview needs to be
how because Charities are selected and
uh who gets the best gaming days and so
forth and so on who gets on the list who
doesn't get on the list and it's
important that that be fair maybe it's
totally fair I don't want to say it's
not but uh I don't I think there there
is uh that it's important that everybody
be on the same page on that so that's
one of the reasons for having this
committee it is a lot of work I just
want to say that getting to
representative Ami's point about
dedicated funds we don't want to set up
something that's uh you know that I'm
going to flounder so I think we do need
to think about whether a committee like
this can can do the job that's being
assigned to it
um and uh I'm not here so much as an
advocate for this is to put it before
you and tell you about it and uh about
the world out there that we all need to
understand and make sure it's
functioning well
so that's I guess that's the long and
short of my uh statement here and I'll
questions and by the way for the record
I am a in this charity gaming business I
have a little operation right down the
street in Concord come and visit
sometime yes representative Spielberg
well if you wanted to see what we do
thank you madam chair
um representative Ames I'm just
wondering if you could give us your own
thoughts about the potential composition
membership of this uh your bill is
straightforward I believe four members
of the house two members of the Senate
so it becomes a legislative task jointly
with the Senate the committee's report
recommends that a commission be formed
that includes legislators the New
Hampshire Lottery Commission Facility
Owners and representatives from the
Charities two different strategies and
I'm just wondering if you could
give us some flavor on what you think
would work better in the public interest
well thank you for asking about that the
the recommendations you're looking at
the recommendations page of the report I
think
there are two paragraphs there the first
paragraph is what I read out and that's
basically the study committee that the
oversight committee that I'm talking
about that's strictly legislative the
second is calling for a commission
um to focus in
directly at the Charities issue
um Senator D'Alessandro filed a bill in
the Senate at senate senate Bill 90
um to do just that and it called for a
an appropriation to support that
commission
um I looked at the docket this morning
for that and it's it looks to me like
it's been ideal'd by this by the Senate
so that's that's gone somewhere that
should be checked on but I think that's
the status of it so this is it and this
is uh just a legislative committee
um I I think if we recommended any more
Senators uh uh we'd get to Nowhere
um and uh maybe this should be more
legislators but six is a six is a pretty
good number and we're getting used to
other comments other questions
representative Phyllis thank you madam
chair
um having been on Edna for four years I
know one time at least one time we had a
bill related to the charitable
um gambling and my recollection is that
there are a limited number of licenses
that can be had for these facilities and
we haven't maxed out on those licenses
yet
so I'm just wondering if part of the
charge for this committee would be to
just look at that the fact you know the
licensing part and and how that fits
I
I would respond to that and say that uh
that would be within the charge it's to
study the oversight and enforcement of
charitable gaming licensure as part of
the oversight enforcement
sorry all me lost my mind thank you our
names are very similar and
do you
no no what's happening to the bills in
the Senate that do deal with the uh
eight license limit until 24 there is
one that that on I think uh
removes that says that that limit is
permanent
on and I think that there's another that
tries to expand it
on to a larger number but still finite
and apparently this these are being
taken debated seriously within the
Senate that and and other issues to do
with with the explosion into real
casinos
I don't know about the Senate bills I do
know that we're about to hear a bill
that um House Bill 607 is that right
um
that's that's uh
that deals with the structure and uh
various sub elements of
the charitable gaming apparatus the
people who run run these gaming
establishments
other questions for the sponsor
okay seeing none thank you very much and
please fill out a pink card I do not
have any more pink cards for House Bill
220 is there anyone else here who would
no okay we will close the public hearing
on House Bill 220 and we will now
open up the house bill 607
and recognize the prime sponsor
representative Doucet
good morning Madam chair members of ways
uh House Bill 607
my synopsis of this is it's pretty much
a housekeeping bill with three very
specific exceptions uh we just heard
um
the growth of charitable gaming in the
state and the fact that that model which
we've heard testimony over the years is
a great model works well for the
charities in the state
many of which
count on the revenues who do their
operations and
many Realms in all our communities
this that I just lost forgive me
this piece of legislation kind of
starts the process of bringing us us up
to speed and we will be examining uh
House Bill 220 that you just heard
testimony on
about getting a committee together to
study charitable gaming but I think we
all can agree that
the model we have is
is in place and it's what we have to
deal with and I totally lost my
presentation yet please bear with me
take your time I just I don't see any
more pink cards from any other senators
or Representatives so if you are here
please send me a pin card so I can
recognize you
ah
the Boom is having Tech problems here to
well I can speak to
probably the biggest of the changes that
that's in this legislation that's
relative to what representative almi
brought up and maybe represented fellows
in the questioning in the prior bill
it's the
for lack of a better term the moratorium
on
the game specific HHR the machines that
are some kind times dubbed as slot
machines and and we've heard testimony
we know that this is not the case what
we did in the legislation was passed
last biennium was to put a moratorium to
a date specific which is a July of
July 1 of 24.
for the purpose of the operators that
applied to and were eligible to
provide that game and their charitable
Gaming facilities
the opportunity
to uh to roll out this game
and to
see the effects positive and negative
for the charities
and the operators in state revenue in
general
in this rollout
I've heard from
uh different folks The Operators
Charities because uh if I can remind you
part of the component of passing HHR was
the ability to double basically take on
a second charity for the day
instead of the charitable gaming
facility servicing one charity on a
specific date they can now service two
if they have the component of HHR
there was some genuine concern
with some on this committee about that
particular game
and the possibility of proliferation
of these Gaming facilities throughout
the state
um and I share that concern quite
frankly I'm from Salem as you all know
uh Border Town that is definitively a
target
for those looking to provide charitable
gaming not only the operators but the
Charities and the charities in the
surrounding areas it's a great pool back
back when they were trying to pass the
uh
Casino legislation
the folks in my town overwhelmingly
supported the legislature did not and in
2006 we ended up with what we have for
model now charitable gaming
with the shared Revenue structure
so
in the passage of the HHR
The Operators if they
submit to Lottery and I'm sure a lottery
can testify to this they have to patch
pass a very thorough background
financial and criminal check
and
it's up to the commission to designate
one or all of those 14 facilities to be
eligible to provide HHR
what I've noticed while we'll roll back
a little bit that that with uh the
rollout from uh from Gel car it was kind
of stagnated time wise and and again uh
Lottery can
testify to this I I'm not exactly sure
how many of the game operators applied
for HHR licenses how many have received
HHR licenses and are currently operating
or how many may still be in the process
of the licensing and background checks
nonetheless
the purpose for the July 1 uh
moratorium date
was was fixed in part as to be able to
review the the effects of HHR the new
game
and uh how things were working out
in my experience over the last year or
so
and I'm sure many of you who are in tune
with what's going on with uh charitable
gaming there's been some
passing of the torch there's been some
larger operators some multinational
operators so some big big companies big
players coming into our state and buying
up these local charitable gaming rooms
and we can all draw our own conclusions
as to why that has happened and I can
also also attest to the fact that again
Salem being
in its geographical place
we we in New Hampshire have 14 Gaming
facilities 14 charitable Gaming
facilities in all of New England these
Mega casinos in Everett uncansville
boxwoods and others Oxford there are a
total of nine casinos in New England we
in New Hampshire have 14 Gaming
I'm a free market person
make no mistake but we set limits we set
limits currently on Gaming facilities
I'm of the belief and this is the major
component of this particular piece of
legislation I'm of the belief that we
should
allow for these 14 licenses there may be
others out there that have not
um
finished up the the process but all of
the belief that we should not have to
use a term from
testimony less biennium
have slot barns showing up on every
corner
I think that there's a place for
charitable gaming a great place we have
some probably I'm guessing probably 1100
Charities that can be serviced I belong
to many of those charities
and they do great work there's also a
saturation point I own some property
myself in Nova Scotia and I can tell you
that I can walk into any restaurant Pub
corner store
in other places in this video gaming
there I don't want to see that in our
our state
so
announcer prevention is worth a pound of
cure here relative to this particular
component
secondly
another piece that I would deem more or
less housekeeping
is the maximum bet component of this at
present a a player can sit at a
blackjack table in one of the charitable
gaming rooms and place a bet at a
um but I that same player can also go to
the 7-Eleven on the corner and buy a
scratch ticket for 25
there just should be some Equity here
and it allows for uh all involved to
reap the benefits of uh the revenue most
specifically the Charities and it keeps
us in line with what the lottery
commission's already doing we already
thirdly is the employees the licenses
for these employees
they're required to go through a
criminal background check a
fingerprinting process annually
which they have to pay out of pocket
and also pay the state I believe it's a
hundred dollar fee for the annual
license
this would extend that to a three-year
period for the license with the caveat
of reporting to the state any changes in
their status
uh criminal history or anything of that
nature
it also changes this definitions in in
the piece of legislation uh talking
about uh primary game operator and uh
primary game employer
a primary game operator in in short is
basically a floor manager a Pit Boss or
somebody who's managing the charitable
gaming facility
so he's the foreman on the job and the
way the law is written right now he also
has to get an annual license but has to
pay a premium pay a 500 annual fee for
um I'm proposing to roll that back to
the 100 and also make it to three year
the the
primary employer is still paying a 750
licensing fee I'm not touching that but
uh
it's nonsensical for the foreman to be
paying a
a 500 fee plus the background checks
annually
um
and the rest is
is pretty much cleanup talking about
photo requirements and such but that
that rolls into the initial licensing
there's another component that speaks to
like many employees in the state
uh that there's a problem with the
Recruitment and Retention of employees
so some of them may work part-time in
one particular facility work part-time
in another facility in this legislation
also allows for them to not have to be
licensed in each they can
uh basically transfer their their
clearance to another
representative
diligently trying to take notes here I
don't like acronyms you use one what's
HHR stand for uh historic horse racing
those are those machines that were
spoken of so lengthy over the past few
years and they finally get passed into
law last year in some of the uh
charitable game operators are at present
operating but I know some may or may not
some may still be in the process of
going through the clearances for that
yeah it occurs to me we have a lot of
new people to this committee who have
never heard about any of this my
apologies so um we do have the Lottery
Commission here behind you so they can
maybe do that if you're not comfortable
doing that any other questions for yes
representative Almy this is rather a
long question as you know on
I've been trying to fight this
proliferation for a long time on I would
like you to go through and tell and tell
us what each change is doing
I can do that
there are severe problems in my
communities
on yeah
yeah well she probably shouldn't have
said that because it was
a comment about the problems in my
okay I don't know that it
that'll address specifics to that but I
can tell you uh
the changes that are basically made in
this what I I blanketly said was
housekeeping
okay
but why
do you include game operator employer
why do you
get rid of primary game operator in the
second one is okay thank you for the
question it's
simply uh the game uh primary game
operator at one point in time early on
they were probably in making an
assumption now and somebody else can
testify to this was probably the primary
employer of that establishment now
adding the the definition of uh game
operated goe game operator employer that
is the employer The Entity that employs
a primary game operator who is
like I said before probably a floor
supervisor the deforming on shift
so that definitively two different
things
thank you
Schamberg has a question I'm sorry this
is for the entire document oh you're
going through the up sorry
continue
so okay
I think that gets us down to line 10.
fans who must get the primary game
operator license I've already explained
that uh
oh ooh something I did miss it removes
the fingerprint requirement for the
member list of the charity applicants
back in the Inception in the early years
of charitable gaming as a charity you
had to be on site in a lot I know at
least in Salem when it was at Rock Park
we had to literally handle the money as
as poker tournaments were going off and
whatnot not necessarily the case now
after the Charities are chosen
and they received their dates
they're not required any longer to be on
premises during those hours of operation
so subsequently why would we need to do
a background check on the treasurer of
it eliminates language about a licensed
equipment dealer again others can speak
to you on I'm sorry which page I'm not
all right just
yeah I can just give you an overview of
the changes that have done a synopsis
what I wanted was Page by page so I'll
just have to try it
spend hours figuring this out right what
I can do representative if you like I
can provide for the committee a synopsis
uh item for item as to what's changing
this and I expect to do that anyway I
did not do that this morning
but uh obvious reasons there's some very
that I can uh single out for the
committee that'll be easy to navigate
through
okay does it make sense because we have
a lot of people that would like to speak
on this bill that um representative you
could follow up with a synopsis of the
key things it does and then where to
find it in the bill it seems like that
would be very helpful we do have a
couple other hands up representative
Schamberg
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative over here thank you for
taking my question uh just the
background are the present owners of
these facilities domestic individuals or
domestic corporations or
any multinational corporations of the
ones here in New Hampshire I I asked
Lottery about that follow-up Madam chair
the second question are there any
restrictions
by state law or federal law to limit it
to individuals or domestic corporations
here in New Hampshire I follow up with
the state yeah okay thank you and let me
just say also
when do you see me with a laptop I had a
problem with my printer this morning or
I would have provided these things for
you and and again apologies you can see
I have a feeling we'll see you back here
so yeah okay uh represent any of us are
sympathetic yes representative fellows I
think hit her hand up
well I'm I'm not too too sure like who
to ask this question one of the my
problems is that
some of these sections repeal what was
there and changed it to something so I
have no idea what the what what's going
on in terms of the change but in terms
of Licensing
um I'm I'm
confuse you have so many levels of
Licensing I think that
the the employees are those all in the
um oplc licenses but but for the whole
facility the whole who whoever gets the
license to say you can even do this that
it is and I'm sure Lottery can
yeah we have the experts right behind
representative Doucet who hopefully will
come up and say what they want to say
okay good any other yes representative
Britain
the license once you get a license
um what is the limitation like a size a
facility that you could can do or is it
just the sky's the limit
um and excuse me but regarding um you
know the chairs offer to uh at least
check out the facility that you haven't
conquered I'd like to take you up on
that I've never been to one and it'd be
kind of good to see something like that
but well as you just mention I think
what represent Ames was talking about
there was a committee and they went on
field trips to different locations right
yeah so that's always something you
should consider doing you might have one
in your community or near your community
go check it out yeah okay
any other questions from representative
Doucet is there a size limitation on the
facility and what's you get a license we
can ask that of the commission that is
something that they would know
yeah representative Phyllis that's one
other thing is there any other state
that has this model with the
um charitable portion of it does do any
other states do anything like that
not to my knowledge not not like we do
okay thank you represent representative
Platt has a question just for the record
I am treasurer of lion sight and hearing
Foundation of New Hampshire Inc and we
okay thank you thank you okay I think
this would be a great time I have New
Hampshire Lottery Commission here
hopefully they'll all introduce
um good morning Madam chair members of
the committee I'm Charlie McIntyre
director of New Hampshire Lottery
and with me is Valerie King who is the
administrator of Licensing
with
New Hampshire lottery specifically for
charitable gambling so
um
first I want to apologize as noted
before there are two very very similar
bills one in the Senate one in the house
we drafted fiscal notes for both
through an error on my part in monolone
one was not submitted to you folks one
was submitted to the house I saw the
calendar Friday that indeed that was the
case or my admin forwarded Monday
morning first thing and so somewhere in
your vast
edifice exists our fiscal note which was
drafted in time but once again I
reviewed it over vacation and the worst
thing you could do is read an email now
it's a red email and you look like when
you go back to Vacation you miss it so
the fault is mine and I apologize to the
chair the members of the committee so a
number of the questions that you would
ask are answered in that fiscal note at
several Pages it goes through the detail
of the changes to the law uh the the
definitions as well as the finances
involved and so uh certainly we can
answer the questions you want to have
now or we're happy to come back another
time
um after you've had a chance to review
it and once again the fault is mine and
so I wanted to lead with that Madam
chair if you apologize and we're um
happy to answer questions on the bill
you would have
um
representative just so we don't have to
look through the edifice to find it
could you forward to the committee
of course I had forwarded uh to Pamela
Ellis uh Monday but I'll certainly
afford it uh Madam chair if you want to
designate somebody I'll forward it to
I could even give you my copy when I
of course happy to do it yeah it'll be
before the well when I want to get back
to my office perfect representative or
did you have a question uh yes thank you
madam chair this being the 21st century
can't we just make a phone call or
something and say send it now
I could actually um I can yes I can yeah
yes representative Albany I think we
desperately need a work session on this
to get the new members a background of
what has happened and why and on and to
go through
the Bell
the Senate Bill we I guess we can't do
that one yet and on the fiscal note
director McIntyre would you be open to
rejoining us for a work session I am
absolutely your your um disposal thank
you thank you so much and Deputy thank
you yeah yeah and that and actually to
that point there's a number of things
for example
um Valerie reports to our chief
compliance officer who may also answer
questions that you would want to have
and I'll have him available would have
him available as well for the members of
the committee or any other
we've heard this this committee was what
we report to so anyone you need we will
thank you for taking my question uh Mr
McIntyre does that mean the two
questions I asked I should wait till
someone else or should I ask Valerie you
could ask them again certainly should we
have an answer yeah thank you madam
chair uh are the present owners of
facilities domestic individuals or
domestic corporations or multinational
corporation or individuals
um
if I recall correctly they're domestic
in terms of their U.S based uh I don't
think they have any interests outside
the country
but they have interest in other states
follow-up
and are there any restrictions by state
law or federal law to limit the
individuals
or these domestic corporations and
sure
if if you mean where they can send their
revenue as in the charitable Revenue
then it has to remain in New Hampshire
so the Charities that they that benefit
from these game dates would be new
representative
thank you but
um by
uh the way that the historic horse
racing which I see in the meat social
media and print media only referred to
as slot machines now on it has a very
large payment goes to the uh place in
South Carolina Florida which on
which runs those machines remotely
um certainly the the breakdown is what
it is it's three quarters goes to the
operator
and all their expenses 25 is split
between the state and the Charities
um the individual Arrangements that each
of the operators has are made with the
what you would call content and
manufacturers
is between them
um I I have an estimate as to what it is
I don't know for sure
and it varies by facility and a number
uh follow up and then representative
fellows so
so we do not have a right to find out
I mean certainly we can
we we do have those one of the
difficulties is the application process
is confidential by law and so I don't
know what I can divulge publicly as to
the numbers break down various contracts
so I the answer is I think we can get
that information I don't know if I can
I would could you just give me some
clarification on that statement you just
made about
um where the money goes you were taught
I think you were talking just about the
horse racing but in general
that that I I want to understand the
business model and what's going on
because you've got the gambling and that
money part some percentage of that is
going to charity and some percentage of
that is going to the state
um
I'm wondering if these entities I assume
they make a lot of money off off the
food and and things that are not part of
the the gambling so I'm just trying to
I've never been to one and I'm just
wondering like what is going what's
going on
um certainly so each of the facilities
is different in the sense of what they
offer inside
and so I'll take for example the
facility which has essentially all of
the revenue streams that you would
imagine it could so we'll say the brook
which is in Seabrook New Hampshire
it has table games for which the state
receives a significant portion of the
funds
Richard receives the funds
and the facility receives the funds and
I can get you the numbers on that
it has historic horse racing for which
as I explained the operator would retain
75 percent to pay all the expenses then
the Charities and the state split 25
percent
they also have a license for sports
betting where
sorry I saw the eyes you asked I'm
surely happy to go into this um and so
which the there's a DraftKings facility
within that DraftKings the facility and
us split the profits on that
they also have food and beverages for
which their revenues are theirs we don't
go into that
they also have a simulcast license for
which they will display horse racing and
individuals can go there and bet on
horse racing
yes
yes I'm okay so it's a live horse race
someplace else shown on a TV screen they
can bet on live
um
and that once again is split most of the
money goes to the operator and the track
that is showing the race we receive a
small amount
that's essentially the the the the gamut
of
activity within a facility and it varies
off of that what each facility does to
what extent
and every time you were saying we were
you you were meaning the state so
there's just a limited
where where does the chair or did were
you did it mean State and charity where
I said we was the state receives funding
for this and the rest of Charities the
chair receives funding for this yes
so I actually representative if it helps
I'm happy to send over a breakdown of
what each
web share model is in terms of each
thing that happens within the facility
if that would make sense to you the
folks and sort of any and all
information you could provide the
members of this committee would be very
helpful and again we'll do a work
session too because it's a little bit
confusing in Matrix form would be great
so you could go down and say this one
does that this one does that yes we're
happy to do it that could be no more
than two pages of a breakdown of each
each event
each function and what the revenue
breakdown is
all right I saw a hand over here
representative liply um just to clarify
I think that's what my question was was
to request that information I'm thinking
about the presentations we've seen from
um agencies kind of to help us
understand the revenue overall and I'm
thinking that same model
um with the revenue broken down by each
um different manner of betting would be
ideal thank you for that just to clarify
Madam chair to the member you mean just
in charitable gambling right not the
overall Lottery breakdown because we
have there's two different sides of the
house it was more than that but so I'm
trying to remember what we've seen from
the Lottery Commission in other
presentations so yes whatever was not
already covered in the presentation if
we could get that background information
that would be very helpful thank you
sure yeah whatever you can do yes
representative all me and just to
clarify on that this year we didn't get
real breakdowns as I recall on on the
different forms of gambling and how much
how what their revenue swore this year
we just got the overall number
yeah certainly I was waiting for an
invitation as to the
after the governor's budget is submitted
in terms of the revenue breakdown
obviously that number was still in flux
because obviously as an executive branch
we're asked to make a revenue estimate
late fall early winter and then to
update that as the budget draws near and
I think we made that estimate
representative I think it was last
Friday so certainly the information was
changing as we
were getting on so happy to come back
and give a revenue estimate breakdown by
category as well as a work session or
representative having not dived deeply
into this bill but scanning it it looks
like it's fairly Broad and covers not
only
the charity gaming but all gaming and so
I would like to see The Matrix cover all
gaming about what covers charity what
does not
the sure thing I mean certainly within
the fiscal note that we didn't send you
admittedly uh as a breakdown of
certainly the changes Val does it
remarkably um thorough job on these
things and so that should help explain a
bunch of it
um
representative Ames
when you do do that
um
explanation or presentation on the
breakout of how the revenues are
allocated
um I think it's important to explain
what the revenues are
so in historic horse racing for example
as I recall the statute
allows
is mutual betting but allows the
uh what is it the commission the
commission The Entity that's running the
historic racing the casino to take out
12 percent from the pool and then that's
the revenue that then is allocated out
so that's an example of just being clear
on what we're talking about so in the
end it's 35 percent of 12 percent
that's that's actually that's correct
um it's 25 of 30 of 12 is
um so and also that number varies it's a
12 is not a fixed number it's it varies
by facility and The Operators will say
floor mix as to what machines are where
and if they pay out
yeah just a follow-up follow-up
um
and that that just triggers this further
uh requests really that um if you can
update us on
how it's playing out because when we did
this bill
um the estimate was I mean the all the
all the numbers assumed 12 percent
but the statute itself says up to 12
percent
and I know some in Kentucky and some
other places uh were leaving more in the
pool so it was
more like 10 percent uh taken out and I
just don't know how it's playing out if
you have any information on that that
would be helpful certainly we would have
that information as as a whole of the
state as well as by facility
and that decision is made by the
for now
certainly the the work session we would
have the opportunity to discuss each
individual points as well that we might
have issues with so sort of leaving my
thumb on the chess piece essentially
okay well it sounds like you have a long
request list thank you very much we will
try to schedule this out we also have
Revenue estimates we have to do soon so
we'll figure out what works yeah
certainly uh our calendar is yours thank
okay we will see them back so don't
don't be worried okay we will now
recognize Rick Newman from the New
Hampshire charitable gaming operators
Association
thank you madam chair
um
good morning members of the committee
Excuse excuse me my name is Rick Newman
I represent the New Hampshire charitable
gaming operators Association
uh which is a Association made up of the
14 facilities that operate charitable
gaming in New Hampshire
and we are here today
uh to support the bill
many of your questions that you asked
are excellent questions and I understand
uh you know some members of this
committee have dealt with charitable
gaming for years and others it's a new
subject to them and I think I'm happy to
be a resource to answer questions if I
can and I know the lottery will be
helpful in that regard I'd like to just
focus on
the bill in front of you and
a few of the changes that it makes to
the current law
I think representative Doucette was
correct that many of the things in the
bill are really sort of housekeeping and
they are issues that were brought um
from the lottery to the study committee
that representative Ames and Doucet
served on items such as no longer
requiring the charity members to be
fingerprinted every year it's because
they don't participate directly in the
charitable gaming that really is
something that is outdated it's
cumbersome it costs the money it's just
not necessary so that's sort of A change
is something that I would consider to be
really to be a housekeeping change I
think the primary
policy changes in the bill I believe in
my view there are there are about four
uh I guess the the largest one is the
language that Fred representative
Doucette was talked about in the
limiting language or what he referred to
as the moratorium
current law says that
with regard to Historic horse racing
machines
only those facilities that were already
licensed and there are 14 of them can
have historic horse racing machines and
that remains the case until July 1 of
2024.
after that anyone operating a charitable
gaming facility would be eligible to
apply for historic horse racing under
the current law this bill
repeals that July 1 24 date so it would
mean that only the 14 current facilities
would continue to be eligible for
historic horse racing if that change is
made now I would point out
that has no effect on how many
charitable Gaming facilities there are
you could open up a charitable gaming
facility tomorrow and offer all the
games that are allowed under law with
the exception of historic horse racing
you can offer roulette Blackjack craps
poker
all of those uh and if you're eligible
you if you qualify you could get a
license tomorrow I would point out that
since in the last three years there has
not been a new applicant for a
charitable gaming facility despite the
fact that they could so I think that's
important to note
the other major policy change here is
the maximum uh wager under the current
law the maximum uh wager that you can
bet on Blackjack craps roulette is ten
dollars
this bill would raise that to 25. it
would also raise what's called
tournament buy-ins buy-in is the amount
of money you pay to enter a tournament
currently the maximum buy-in allowed
under the largest 250 dollars this would
raise that to 2500.
now that may seem like that may seem
like a big leap and I don't think we're
going to see very many twenty five
hundred dollar tournaments in New
Hampshire
um but I think it's possible that down
the road somebody might want to run like
a big tournament once a year or
something but we need the changes in the
wager and the tournament to be able to
stay competitive with what goes on
around us in other states people can
drive to Oxford in Maine or to Encore
down in Everett or Eve Foxwoods and they
can play table games at a much higher
rate than the 10 maximum that we have
uh one of one of the reasons one of the
issues that comes up with regard to the
charitable Gaming facilities relative to
the wager is
obviously the wager limit limits the
revenue to the facility which limits the
amount of money available to pay
employees now with all that we know has
been going on since covet and all the
issues related to any business getting
employees I can tell you can represent
to you that the pay rate the pay rates
of dealers and other employees these
facilities has risen dramatically just
to be able to retain them
and the game operators need
to have a wager increase
partly to be able to continue to pay the
employees the larger
wages that they're getting that they
were getting versus five years ago
so um but it really is about when it
comes particularly to the tournaments
it's about competition poker players
will travel uh you there are lots of
Poker forums that you can log into and
you read and people talk about they're
traveling to New York and they're
traveling you know they'll drive 100 200
300 miles to go to a competitive poker
tournament and that happens throughout
New England and right now we're limited
to a Max of 250 we can have one
tournament a day at 250 and that just is
not competitive with surrounding states
so that's the reason that we need we're
asking for the increase and I think the
third thing is the changing of the
licenses from one year to three and I
just point out I think it was
representative fellows who asked the
question about licensing
every employee associated with gaming in
the facility has to have some kind of a
license so you have a game operator
employer that's the owner primary game
operators are basically shift
supervisors of people who are manager
aerial and then secondary game
operators are the other employees people
who are dealers and that sort of thing
work the cage but all of them go through
a licensing process
under the current law they are required
to get fingerprinted and a criminal
background check every year this changes
that to three every third every three
years and we just think that's efficient
it does require that they keep the
commission up to date on any changes
that affect their licensing and that's
done by filing an annual report and
paying the fee they otherwise would have
paid
um
we just think those that changes will be
very helpful and it's it seems like you
know we've got about a thousand
employees in charitable gaming and
um you know right now every single one
of them have to go get fingerprinted
somewhere and go through a criminal
background check every year we don't
think that's necessary
and one final thing I will say is
there's uh that I think is a significant
policy change in the bill is the current
law Maxes the bond requirement for the
facility at five hundred thousand
dollars and this bill raises that to a
million and we think that's a good
change too particularly with the
addition of historic horse racing
so with that Madam chair I would ask for
your support of the bill happy to answer
any questions and work with any
subcommittees that you may have
representative Allman thank you just
clear something up I think it was
representative fellows who assumed that
the employees were on regulated by olpc
but uh in this case it's all lottery
right that is correct they're they're
not they're regulated by the lottery
only
representative jinnigan
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
um
you mentioned that going to 25 would
help us be more competitive as a as a
state is 25 competitive or what are
other states
um actually two two parts of that one is
Max wager and also the twenty five
hundred dollars you talked about are
both those numbers competitive with
other states do they need to be higher
or is that a good number Most states in
fact I think all of them have no
statutory limit on Wagers in their
Casino so
um I think the facilities for my
experience has been facilities will
oftentimes limit you'll see 500 dollars
is typical at Foxwoods for instance is
the maximum wager you can make so in
terms of what are is 25 competitive with
Encore no because Encore has unlimited
wages frankly
I don't think the legislature would give
us unlimited wages we'd certainly like
to have it but so we're trying to move
the ball a little as we've done over the
past 18 years
but New Hampshire's approach to gambling
is unique in that the question was asked
whether states do it this way the answer
to that is no every other state that has
what you would call you know casino type
gambling it's commercial gambling with
the no charity component and with
representative
ulery and then Ames
thank you very much could you uh please
discuss how we have 14 licenses which
would remain the same
and would not expand
so
is there a competitive market for that
if we were to
um
cap the The Market at 14 would that
limit any future ghost of growth of this
industry or would it lead to what I seem
to see taking place larger corporations
buying the license of a smaller
charitable gaming operation to
conglomerate it into a let's say a uh a
residential destination Casino
could you discuss that I don't think I
can answer the second part of your
question but I would want to clarify we
don't limit the number of Charity Gaming
facilities that can exist in New
Hampshire right now you can we there
could potentially be a hundred two
hundred whatever
anybody can apply and if you're if you
qualify you can get a charitable gaming
license okay so we do only have 14 right
now
the limit that is in place right now is
those are the only 14 places where
historic horse racing can take place
okay so if you were to open up a
charitable gaming operation in Plaistow
for instance you could have all the
games that the other rooms have except
the HHR machines so there is no limit I
would as I pointed out my testimony
there has not been a new applicant or a
new facility open uh in the last
and I think probably five years uh which
says to me
we're at a good spot in terms of what
the market can bear if there were
opportunities for others to make money
in it I would assume that people would
follow up
follow up uh thank you
um so let's say you have a
moderately sized operation in a one of
the border cities
if it were to move into another bigger
facility
it would expand its the number of tables
the number of personnel being employed
the number uh number of uh classes of uh
adult beverages that were being served
uh all that would take place and if we
were to increase the table stakes and
the buy-in for poker games that would
attract a larger crowd would it not
we would hope it would yes so to follow
up on the point
on that point would be
if
that is that considered a new facility
opening up or are they just taking the
down here and moving it over there
under the current law a facility one of
the 14 facilities could do exactly what
you just said they could move uh for the
purposes of having the store course
racing they could move from one location
to another within the same community
okay so yes in that sense it would be
moving that license from Main Street to
F Street if that were the case and
trying to think if anybody's done it
um to my knowledge nobody has done it
yet but they are working on it in
Lebanon and they are working on it in
Salem
and Nashua you're absolutely right they
did do it the river moved to a facility
now called the lucky moose in Nashua
yes
okay representative Ames had a question
I think you got a question yeah thank
you
um
this may be too broad but um I received
this in the mail which presumably from
you
um just yesterday as I came home from a
long day at the legislature
this is uh this is from the New
Hampshire charitable gaming operators
Association which is I think you're
that's correct what you're representing
um and it's impressive document oh it
has your name on the back
um and uh
um so my that's a backdrop
uh I suppose a side question is did you
mail it to everybody sitting here it was
that was mailed to all members of the
House and Senate okay good
um
this is the broad question how are you
doing how's business uh for your casinos
are you booming
are you struggling because you need uh
you're there too many uh limitations on
what you do you've got uh Massachusetts
um you know pushing its casinos its big
Encore casino it's uh
it's I don't know how I was doing post
uh covid but now it's post covet and so
probably more activity there
uh Massachusetts gotten into sports
gaming which I know is not directly
charitable gaming but the latest model
has like the book has a sports book
right there and so it's uh it's part of
the deal and part of the attraction how
are we doing with this well it is a
mixed bag I will tell you the facilities
that have opened up historic horse
racing which I think are just about half
of them maybe a couple maybe one or two
more than half
um they're doing those those machines
are doing well and generating good
Revenue they're bringing facilities that
in the past were not making money to be
profitable
um we do see you mentioned the post
covet World particularly in
Massachusetts now there for a long time
Massachusetts casinos were not doing
poker poker is a very important part of
of the casino environment and since they
weren't doing it that was benefiting
rooms in New Hampshire they are now
aggressively getting back into Boca
which is why we're asking for the
tournament and the wager increase
frankly but the tournament uh increased
because we want to be able to be
competitive with with them we we need
that increase in order to do that
um so
that has affected the Border you can see
the numbers have dropped a little and I
anticipate they will drop a little more
on the border uh casinos charity casinos
in particular because of the poker uh
marketing that the Encore and others
down in Massachusetts are doing overall
I will tell you that
five years ago there were probably
I would say at least half of the charity
gaming rooms were either breaking even
or not making a profit and I believe
that today I could say that they're
probably all making a profit some small
because they don't have HHR yet but uh
but HHR certainly helped those that have
it
I have one follow-up
yeah
um
so you mentioned one of one of the uh
Parts changes made in this bill raising
the debt limit and the
Buy in a number for
poker if I've got the right word I don't
know
um is partly a response to competition
in Massachusetts and my question is
whether they're whether we should be
worried and as you might be about uh
the potential for
foreign
problem gaming is that what you asked
yeah
so I really am not you're at a higher
level of money and interest perhaps an
attraction to the game
so the only thing I would say is I mean
I'm I'm not qualified really to know if
if bigger limits would mean people would
would problem gamer would bet more
because they have to have the money to
bet but I would point out that for
instance in sports betting in New
Hampshire there's no limit on how much
you can bet on sports betting and you
know you see the ads and watching the
Super Bowl you see are ads for places to
bet on on Sports you can bet on you know
who's going to catch the next pass and
all that sort of thing and that's going
on in New Hampshire today I I honestly
believe it's not my bias because I
represent charity gaming I honestly
believe sports betting presents a much
bigger problem potential problem for
problem gaming than what you see in a
casino environment
oh thank you for that Insight thank you
my representative Malloy and then
representative ORS thank you
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question this is
kind of a follow-up on what
representative Ames
I think was working toward but my
question is more direct what would
change How would
Unlimited
Wagers
in New Hampshire change
our charitable gaming business model
here you mentioned earlier
that you know the legislature would
approve that may not but I'm just
curious to know how would if it did if
we did how would it change charitable
gaming here in New Hampshire revenue and
all that so excuse me so whether you
increase it to 25 or some other number
the the biggest change is people tend to
go out in groups right we don't I mean
most of us we have friends who family
you go out with
I would say that a vast number of people
who bet in casinos want to be at a ten
dollar or five dollar table but there
are some that want to be at a higher
table
now if we're going out with four or five
of us together
and you know I I want to be at a 25
blackjack table and you're happy with a
five dollar table then all five of us
are going to probably end up going
somewhere a week where we could all get
what we want so we lose that business we
end up going to Encore instead of
stopping a Nash or Salem okay uh it's
and so so raising the state to any level
keeps some of that business whatever
that limit is going to be we'll keep
some of that business right here in New
Hampshire one of the things we find is
that yes Encore is a beautiful facility
but the facilities that we have are also
very well done and the fact that they're
smaller they're they are attractive to
some players they don't want to go
through the you know you need a shuttle
to get through the parking lot and and
you know deal with all of the hubbub
that happens down at a big Casino so
stopping at the brook or stopping in
Salem makes sense to them but having
that larger bet will mean more of them
will be
taking making that stop instead of
continuing to the next state
so I think that's the way that's the
biggest change it will get us
make us more competitive
to keep more of the customers here in
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question so why is the sports
betting a problem you mentioned the next
past whatever what's the problem with
that no I I was only saying that in
terms of the question regarding problem
gaming which I am not an expert on at
all
uh it has just simply been my
observation
that because you have so many elements
so many ways to bet you can bet every 30
seconds or so on an online app in sports
betting it would be my opinion
not based on any scientific data but my
opinion that sports betting is more apt
to be uh
to be a target of people with problem
gaming than a charity Casino environment
okay very good follow-up please
so
you mentioned that
currently there's these limits on Wagers
and the Charities and the state get 25
percent is that what I heard earlier
today I don't think you said it but I
think I heard it earlier today so just
to be clear on that on the on table
games whether it's poker or blackjack or
craps the charity gets 35 percent of the
revenue from those tables and the state
gets 10.
on historic horse racing
there's 25 percent of the revenue is
comes out we call it a takeout
and that is split
between the state and the charity the
charity gets 35 percent of that and the
state gets 65 percent of that okay very
good so here's my question so what if we
were to just
take the limits off of everything what
is it you would want and what would be
the increase to our charities in the
state any idea well if you increase uh
Wagers whether it's the 25 like this
bill does or some other number I will
tell you Senate Bill 120 in the senate
for instance has passed the Senate once
it has a limit of fifty dollars so that
you'll you'll probably see Senate Bill
120 at some point I would assume but
what would it do to charity Revenue it
would do it would lift all boats yeah
well my my point was what about the
percentage so if we
were to give you carte blanche what
would you want that cap to be or would
we just take the cap off that's what I'm
asking and then what would the
percentages be back to the state and the
Charities that you think we could get in
other words I'm saying like you just
said
whatever if you do if you take the Caps
off it's going to raise all the bolts
that's what I'm saying I want to raise
the money for the staff I don't gamble I
don't care uh how's that full disclosure
but what I am asking is if we're to just
let you do whatever you wanted to keep
the customers to bring them here
you know to build a bigger because
whatever it is what is it you would want
and what's the what's the payout to the
state I think the uh 35 from tables and
10 percent of the state is a fair a
division that leaves 55 percent we got
into what to wagering because if wager
increases that's gonna you're gonna get
more money to the more dollars to the
charity and the state uh 35 and 10 has
worked it worked at a two dollar bet
it's working at a ten dollar bet it
would work at a 25 bet it would work at
a hundred dollar bet okay so would you
be in favor of taking the Caps off
just take the Caps off right
I mean would you be in favor of that and
why or why not
you mean take the Caps off the Wagers
yeah of course I'm sure we would we
would be in favor though okay I don't
think that's viable but I but we'd
certainly be in favor of it I'm in favor
of it but we appreciate that thank you
representative always who I saw first
and then we'll go there
thank you I've got two questions so I'll
just ask one now on
what is the maximum bet on the historic
horse racing machines now and what is
the maximum yes uh 25 is the maximum bet
and this bill would not change that
and that can be done every five seconds
I think it could potentially I don't
think it's practical but yes right my
other questions related but I'll wait
okay representative fellows thank you I
I just wanted clarification on
the T when you say from the table games
35 goes to charity and 10 goes to the
state of 35 and 10 of what it's not the
bet it can't be that much it's a very
good question representative uh thank
you uh 35 of what we call in the
business gross Gaming revenue gross
Gaming revenue is the money left over
after prizes are paid
so basically it'll be it's also would be
called House win
what the house won on that particular
table
some sort of percentage that you can
tell us related to the bets that are
going down which Max which the max is
25.
what
I'm sorry I don't understand the
question
so what does the gross Gaming revenue
what percent is that usually of a bet
well that's very difficult to say on a
table game because
there actually are days when a house can
lose right I mean you could have
somebody get hot on the roulette wheeler
on a crap table and at the end of the
day the house ends up with a negative
number there is no house when so some
days you can win some now that doesn't
happen very often but it can happen it's
it's very difficult
unlike for instance historic horse
racing whereas representative Ames
pointed out the the absolute maximum
house win is going to be 12 percent of
the bets you really can't put a number
on the table games like that
it's going to be it's going to vary from
time to time but if you'll if you will
let me say this with the caveat that
please don't hold me to it
I will tell you that I think most people
in the industry would say that something
between 15 and 20 percent
is about what you can anticipate the
okay
thank you
um thanks for taking my question thank
you for your very cogent kind of
breakdown of what we're talking about
with the four points that helped me a
lot
um I have two questions one is when I
volunteer in my school my child's school
I have to get fingerprinted
so it my question is why would you not
want your employees fingerprinted every
year
um because it seems like professionally
it's their job to work in gambling and
to handle lots of money
um is it really such a big inconvenience
you know it's not a it's not a game
stopper or Game Changer but
um
we think that I mean first of all
and the lottery would know this more
than I but
I think I would know if we'd ever found
an employee getting fingerprinted for
Renewal that turned up something that
ended up getting them denied a license
right employees know that I mean if an
employee knows they broke the law and
they've done something bad in all
likelihood they're gonna not come back
because they know they're going to get
picked up they're gonna it's gonna get
caught so so it seems I guess our
position is on that point that it's just
redundant that it has to happen every
single year and it costs the employee
money and it costs time and it's it's
inconvenient right it's not something
that we would say is essential to the
legislation but it would certainly be
more convenient representative
if you place odds on the passage of this
bill
I'm not a bookie
representative
on
related to the other question
um there are charitable gaming places
that put more emphasis on the machines
and their charitable gaming places that
put more emphasis it looks like on poker
and other table games
and um in Lebanon there is a small place
that most people didn't even know was
there on
which is in the middle of a area of
subsidized housing
who are people that would just go to
machines usually is there a question
here and and it's moving to a place that
is next to our major thrift store uh and
the cheapest supermarket
so um it seems to be that as an example
on and then the Brooks seems to be
heavily oriented towards getting people
in for the other games
is there a question there the question
was uh how many of these I think they're
only eight now with
with the machines
I I think that may be right it does
change that's six that don't even have
this question yet but of the ones that
have the machines how many of them are
are
um pushing or getting more Revenue out
of the machines than they are out of the
are you asking I'm sorry I don't I'm not
clear on the question on their
to
are they making more money out of these
historic horse racing machines or are
they making more money out of the the
other games
or are they trying to make more money
well I I think obviously to try to
maximize Revenue any way they can but I
would point out that in the rules that
were adopted
the facility has to have a ratio of
revenue from uh table games
versus revenue from machines oh it does
6.33 it's a factor of six point so the
revenue for HHR machines
uh cannot exceed I think it's six point
three three percent uh 6.33 times the
revenue from table games and if it does
the the rate goes up from 25 to 50
percent
okay so that's a dramatic increase the
rate of what the rate of the takeout so
the the charity money goes
charity actually ends up getting another
25 if it exceeds that ratio
what's six and a third times
the the amount coming out of the table
games correct
questions yes representative liply quick
one
um
the speaker has indicated he's not a
specialist on problem gaming and
understand that I'm wondering if the
committee could invite someone who could
help us understand because when we talk
about tobacco or alcohol we know there's
a cost to society right of problem uses
of that and there would be a cost to
Society of the problem
um gambling and I'm wondering if
um
and this would be bigger it wouldn't
just be the charity gambling but it
would be I wonder if the Lottery
Commission would be who we could ask
yeah because obviously there's a lot of
economic charitable gaming is one
element of what the Lottery Commission
does but they also do scratch tickets
and probably other things I don't even
know about so I think we'll have to ask
them when they return to help us
understand that piece I just want to
make sure that if we're capturing
Revenue are we accounting for any cost
and do we know there is a special
fund maybe for that and they would know
that so we'll ask them so I can tell you
that with the passage of House Bill 626
two years ago that authorized historic
horse racing
um there is money that it's called
breakage breakage is the leftover
pennies that are that accumulate in
paramutual wagering and that money goes
to prob to the problem gaming fund and I
can say
just give you an idea I mean not again
what not everybody up and running yet
but I believe that's averaging somewhere
around 11 000 a month the last I saw it
it's probably growing as more and more
historic racing machines come online
and just to clarify my question is not
just what Revenue we're capturing which
that's really helpful but also if
there's some way that the state is
quantifying a cost
any other questions we have a few more
people who are going to testify on this
bill too so we might be able to ask them
okay great thank you so much thank you
madam chair
okay we will now recognize Tina Andrade
from the home health and hospice care
good morning and thank you so much
welcome for allowing us me to speak and
I'd like to offer another perspective if
I may
and I'm um the director of philanthropy
for home health and hospice care and the
community hospice house
and we were one of the first
organizations the charitable
non-profits to take advantage of
charitable gaming
and I would say that last year
we received a check for our week that
was about 71 000 dollars
and I'd like to let you know what we did
with that money
so we're an old organization we were
founded in 1883
still going strong we served 25 cities
and towns in Southern New Hampshire and
on any day we probably have about 500
patients most of them are cared for in
the home setting so we have about 250
clinicians and they're driving all over
New Hampshire and and going up to
people's doors and helping those folks
stay independent in their homes in
addition to that
we do Hospice Care in nursing homes in
people's homes and in the community
hospice house where we have a 10 Suite
10 beds where we take care of folks at
end of life who for whatever reason and
there are a couple of different reasons
they cannot be cared for in the home
setting
it has been our mission since 1883 to
care for people whatever their financial
circumstances are
and that means if a person has no
insurance has no resources we try very
desperately to care for them nonetheless
and that includes in the community
hospice house
now I think I should let you know that
there are only two hospice houses in the
whole state of New Hampshire we're one
of them
and both of them
are non-profit organizations we do have
um
for-profit hospices
but they don't have hospice houses
anywhere not in New Hampshire not across
the country and the reason for that is
because hospice houses run at a deficit
so the rest of our business in the home
setting and that's why we're still here
today
is because yes that does bring in a
revenue to support that work
the hospice house does not and in fact
even when you have Medicare or private
insurance or your own resources every
day that a patient is in there we lose
probably about a little over four
hundred dollars a day
and that's why we have a philanthropy
Department
and so in a number of different ways we
raise money we're a little department
just four of us and we raise money
through events through direct mail
solicitations
through Memorial gifts and through
grants and now the Brilliance of the
State of New Hampshire in bringing us
charitable gaming
in little community
casinos
so when we get that wonderful
last year 71 000 what that meant
very directly
is several patients
dying in the community hospice house
I don't know if any of you have had an
experience with someone in hospice
or in a community hospice house
but I have to say that every single day
there are notes that come to my desk in
the mail
sometimes with a five dollar gift
sometimes with a fifty dollar gift but
always always
with something that someone wrote about
their experience
and what amazes me
is that despite great sorrow
in the loss of a loved one
the way people express it is it was the
most beautiful experience for us
I got a letter recently from a woman
whose family member had died four years
ago in the hospice house and she retold
in the letter
what an incredible experience it was for
them and she wrote at the time my
sisters and I didn't realize it you were
taking such wonderful care of our dad
we didn't realize it but you were also
taking great care of us
so I think it's important
in the big perspective
you know to know what our Charities are
doing
and how absolutely important this is to
us
if we didn't have the Hospice House
people would die anyway
but they may die in a hospital setting
much more expensive both for families
for insurance for the State of New
Hampshire and for communities and taking
up a bed
that someone who may go into the
hospital and recuperate
would be able to have
so
we now have the historic horse racing
machines
my organizations weak starts next Monday
and we are so grateful to be able to do
this because we know it will directly
affect people in our community directly
affect them
now that we have historic horse racing
machines
there now are two Charities a week
that would be
um
that would receive the gift
two Charities a week so I know that this
this next week we will receive a
charitable gift it won't be quite as
much
so when we talk about raising the bet
that a person can make we know lots of
people won't go up to the 25 because
people just don't they know what their
limits are these are small places
they're Community places
there's one 10 minutes away from my own
house that I've certainly been at and
see everybody I know you know it's just
it's a safe place people are having fun
and most of the bats will be small bats
but it would be wonderful to be able to
be back at that level that we were
before because for us
that is just I can see patients a woman
came up to me at a Rotary meeting on
Monday and she had a story and she was
saying that she had a friend that needed
hospice help but they didn't have any
insurance what could we do about it and
I said please let us know have the
doctor refer that patient you know
that's exactly why we are a non-profit
organization because
whether you're a prince or a popper you
would get the same exact care at the
community hospice house
and the this particular bill
will just simply make it possible for
someone else like that to have their
last few days
in a place like ours
and so I urge you today
to consider this perspective I know
you've spent a lot of time today talking
about the ins and outs of it as you
should without any question
but New Hampshire has done a brilliant
thing than most other states have done
I know you're going to hear from a
couple other non-profits
um today but I just want you to see
very clearly
what this is doing and it's a good thing
does anyone have any questions for me
yes sir for the record I just want to
say
um what you do is amazing I've
experienced it personally so thank you
representative
yes I have
take my composure for a moment
um is there a limit to how often you can
come to the uh the gaming association
yes only uh once a week
oh could I I forgot I'm sorry getting a
little older
um I wanted to address the
fingerprinting briefly
because I have first-hand experience
so the first year I knew I was the one
that would pick up the check so I went
down to the police station
you know and I did the digital and they
sent it up to wherever they send it I
think that they send it to the FBI but
at any rate it came back that they
couldn't read it so I went back to the
police station and they did it with ink
and we did the resent it off and they
called me up and said sorry you seem to
have no fingerprints
and I thought oh perhaps I should have
been a cat burglar but at any rate then
we went and I had another person in my
office go she called the Nashville
police department and said could I come
this afternoon and they said oh no we
just brought a whole bunch of criminals
in so don't come today
the next time I got another person in
our office the director of Home Care
Lucy and Lucy went to the police station
same problem Lucy and I decided she had
no fingerprints so Lucy and I decided
this probably because we have Ray nodes
you know not our fingers are always cold
at any rate what I do want to say about
this is I think it's actually
probably taxing on the police department
but although they have to speak for
themselves but in our organization you
know we have criminal records checks
done every single year on every employee
because
we work with people in the community and
so just something to think about I
suspect that our fellow non-profits
probably do the same thing now I'm sorry
you did have questions
thank you very much for your testimony
Kevin Jordan sorry it took me a minute
to read your first name I should have
recognized you apologies from the New
Hampshire law enforcement memorial
commission association association thank
you thank you that's who I'm
representing today
um that's why I'm in plain clothes
actually and my real life I'm the chief
of law enforcement New Hampshire Fish
and Game so Madam chair thank you uh and
I appreciate all of the members of the
House Ways and Means Committee I've
learned a great deal sitting here today
A lot that I did not know about gambling
I'm not a gambler I lost fifty dollars
many years ago in Las Vegas and it
bothers me to this day
um so I don't do that but I have as a
result of my charity uh we have
benefited from uh the monies that come
into New Hampshire for under charity
gaming
so the law enforcement memorial
Association was created many years ago
to recognize and memorialize the
ultimate sacrifices made by the men and
women who have lost their lives while
protecting New Hampshire citizens the
association also recognizes those
sacrifices made by the family and
friends survivors of these New Hampshire
Heroes each year during the month of May
out here on the front lawn as most of
you know we hold a ceremony during law
enforcement week to honor those
sacrifices and to memorialize those
officers
as a non-profit which we are our
greatest challenge has always been
fundraising
we don't receive any state funding for
this organization we operate solely
based upon donations
the cost to hold these annual ceremonies
during Police Week each year continues
to increase and the currently the cost
for this event alone near seven thousand
dollars annually we put the flowers in
and maintain the memorial grounds out
here as well each year
so a few years ago we quite by luck were
offered the opportunity to participate
in the charitable gaming and that was my
first exposure to that and we partnered
up with Boston Billiards in Nashua New
Hampshire through this young lady
sitting behind me Gia
uh and I'm I'm here to tell you that
certainly saved our organization
um we no longer have to struggle to get
enough donations to maintain the
memorial or the grounds surrounding that
site out front here we've been able to
meet the cost of conducting an annual
ceremony for the families
we do support the change uh in this bill
and the increase in the ability to place
bets from the current ten dollars to a
25 limit one of the concerns I had when
I when I asked about this change was the
fact that there are New Hampshire
citizens are quite possibly New
Hampshire citizens that are leaving our
state to spend this money in other
states to me that makes no sense I would
like to see the state New Hampshire
economy benefit from that it seems like
a modest change to me
um I think it's important for us to
promote our own economy and encourage
those people to place those vets here in
New Hampshire not only help our economy
it'll benefit the very valuable
non-profits that that also benefit from
this charity gaming
I would like to Echo the concerns or the
or the praise really for the legislature
to take you know sitting here I'm
watching this and you're taking very
careful contemplation of all of this and
I appreciate that as a citizen I think
it's important to me I have mixed I've
always had mixed feelings about gambling
but I've also had an opportunity now to
see the benefits from it when it's
controlled and managed and I believe
that you folks are doing a very good job
trying to do that so I I give you a lot
of credit for that
uh the other thing I want to speak to
was the fingerprint requirement that
happened so every year I go down at the
end of the year to get when we have our
week and I have to pick up the check uh
that comes to the law enforcement
memorial and I have to be fingerprinted
and I thought being in this field that
I'm in and have been in for three
decades would exempt me from that it
does not I have to get fingerprinted uh
and have my background check the one
thing I would and so when they when I
saw in the bill that this was going to
change it kind of made sense to me I do
share concerns brought out this morning
about you know are we concerned about
people
um you know getting into trouble and I
guess I would say this for you to
consider or ask you to consider this in
the law enforcement field when I signed
up to be a police officer some 32 years
ago I had my background done my
fingerprints were taken and my criminal
background was checked as I sit here 32
years later it's never been done again
with the exception of the time when I go
down to Boston Billiards to get my check
for my non-profit so we're allowing guys
who carry guys and gals carry guns and
have the rights to take away people's
rights
frankly we're not requiring them to be
checked every year so I would think that
this would be safe to do in this field
is my opinion
I am concerned about uh and I and I've
learned more today than I've ever known
about the HHR machines I'm the only
concern in in Boston Billiards has moved
to that and we've been told that we're
going to be sharing a week with another
charity I don't have a problem with that
the the money that we get certainly is
sufficient to run it to run our program
I am concerned If This Were to open up
Statewide and we would dilute that
opportunity that the Charities would
then suffer so I am very much in favor
of limiting that I think that's
important to consider when you're making
um and I don't most of everything else
that I had written down here has already
been discussed so I don't want to take
up any more of your time but I would
respectfully ask you
to consider carefully as you're doing
from sitting back here watching it
listening to it that you support House
Bill 607 as we move forward thank you
very much Madam chair
thank you for your testimony
representative Platt are you aware if
there's a central repository for
fingerprints
there is yes so those are main those are
not thrown away they are maintained by
the FBI so your prince would go to the
FBI they would go through safety
department of safety and then to the FBI
for for analysis or checking follow up
please
if so why do we require fingerprinting
at all if there are already fingerprints
on file well that that is that is my
question I guess although not everyone
has I guess arguably not everyone in the
world has been fingerprinted
um you know unless they've they've been
required to under a certain but once
that occurs there's no value to redoing
that other than checking a background
checking a criminal record
I will say that anyone convicted of a
misdemeanor or above crime doesn't do
that quietly it hits the newspapers and
that's not something that you can keep
quiet
representative Britain so maybe it's in
okay Madam chair but maybe it's in the
legislation but um regarding the benefit
that's paid to a non-profit yeah now
does a non-profit have to be in the
municipality that a gaming
building is or it does not no the
requirements for a non-profit must be
that you must be a non-profit in good
standing so you must be registered with
the state you must be registered with
charitable trust you have to produce and
you have to have the IRS standard or
meet that standard and all of that
paperwork is required to be filed each
year with the gaming
institution that's going to contribute
to you but there's not a requirement for
you to be in that area for instance law
enforcement memorial is housed out of
Concord and and we receive generous
donations from Nashua from Boston
Billiards to follow so follow up and
then representative blood has a
follow-up so is it realistic to think
that um myself who's an executive
director of uh transport Central
nonprofit in Plymouth might be able to
apply for something like this yes I
would say that it is yes the other thing
I just want to add and maybe a lot of
you know that I didn't have a very in
law enforcement I have very good feeling
about gambling casinos
based on my training and experience I
will tell you that opinion changed when
I spent some time and I can only speak
to Boston Billiards and I'm not here to
promote Boston Billiards but it's the
one I'm familiar with I went in there
it's a very professionally run
organization I watched the balance and
checks from a corner and it's and it's
run the way I would expect it to be run
and I left there much more confident
about gaming in the way New Hampshire
controls it than I ever had prior to
that so just something for you to think
about thank you thank you
just a statement I know firsthand that
it used to be you have to be a 501c3
that's changed so a 501c4 can now also
apply
yes I know a 501c3 can I'm not familiar
when we do the work session we can drill
down on that unless you would like to
fill out a pin card but we're going to
fall into a follow-up work session thank
you very much for your testimony and we
will make sure oh I'm sorry do we have a
question over here oh representative
already apologize yes sir just to switch
hats a second too yes sir you're a law
enforcement officer in fish and games I
am yes sir now
just a little bit on background checks
yes
with a law enforcement agency yes do
they do the FBI check or do they just do
the state police check both of which are
considered background checks right and
if I'm correct and correct me if I'm
wrong the state police check is only a
record not of arrests
but only of convictions that appear on
the state police Forum doesn't talk
about arrest it doesn't talk about court
appearances it only talks about
convictions that so you're correct on a
couple of different levels so state law
enforcement agencies do a uh
mind-boggling background it's a complete
background to include FBI records FBI
numbers if one exists we go back we my
agency we go to the elementary school
where the officer attended school we
start there and work our way up so those
are pretty complete at the state level
and most most cities now I believe with
leeak with the implication of the liac
commission most cities I think are now
doing that as well you would be correct
a state if you were to run my background
at New Hampshire State Police or
Department of Safety you would find only
convictions that have occurred in the
state of New Hampshire you would not
find for instance I just ran an
individual
who is going to be applying for a guides
license in New Hampshire sure his record
was clear and we found his record was
certainly not clear when we left the
state and went to other states called
the triple I investigation so you would
be accurate
follow-up
thank you madam chair uh this is for
information I believe
um I'm also aware that private
investigators have both a FBI check yes
the triple I check and they also check
with the RCMP
um because of the type of activities in
which they're engaged sure and I believe
some of the youth activities also
require a multiple State Check Yes uh
because of the chance for child abuse
but the term background check as it
otherwise appears in law
only applies to the Sur surface check
that is done by the New Hampshire State
Police is that more or less a correct
analysis or New England yes yes that's a
that's a pretty good analysis yes that's
a that's a very general term thank you
yes sir
okay oh do we have any more questions
over here thank you so much for your
testimony okay the chair will recognize
John Eric keso
from Meals on Wheels of Hillsborough
County
thank you madam chair and thank you uh
to the to the chair representatives for
having me here so I'm the chairman or
excuse me I'm the president and CEO of
Meals on Wheels of Hillsborough County
we're an essential service we're a
beneficiary of charitable gaming uh God
bless charitable gaming they have saved
us more than once uh the
um couple things I'll say briefly are
that
um the Crim criminal checks I've been in
human services serving vulnerable
populations for more than 40 years I've
had background checks I've had criminal
checks Galore
first time I've been fingerprinted was
for charitable gaming and now I have to
do it every year so I'd love to not
doing it's it's a nightmare having to do
it
um and sharing of days because the uh
charitable gaming now has to be shared
by two Charities our our
um
benefits from Cheryl gaming have been
reduced considerably so anything you can
do to bolster charitable gaming is great
raising the BET limit is wonderful
taking the bent limit away I don't know
whatever you need to do to help
charitable gaming uh is a really great
thing and representative Ames you had
asked how the charitable gaming outfits
were doing and that was a really great
question I'm here to say how are the
Charities doing
um
we're struggling with inflation energy
costs for me food costs Meals on Wheels
I got to pay more for gas and food I've
got I raise a million dollars a year
I've got to figure out how to raise a
million two next year because of the
costs so whatever you can do to help
with charitable gaming it benefits our
Charities it would be most appreciated
and that's all I have to say
thank you so much for your testimony
other questions
people might be getting hungry for lunch
thank you so much for coming I do not
have any more pink cards is there anyone
else here who would like to say
something no okay we will now close the
public hearing on House Bill 607 and we
will schedule a work session which will
be noticed in the calendar for everyone
yeah we have until 1 15 so you have
about 40 minutes to take a lunch break
and uh then please come back we all have
Public public hearing starting at 1 15.
um thank you very much
I'm representative Timothy Horgan from
Stratford County District 10 which uh
has no cigar shops in it although we're
right next to uh Dover which does have a
federal cigar shop
um
and uh so
actually probably most of you know this
already but uh what is a premium cigar
so I'm just say there's a more precise
definition but those are those pixie
cars which are wrapped by hand in
tobacco leaves
rather than uh wrapped by a machine and
paper they're much more expensive than
cigarettes little cigars or regular
cigars and the previous cigars are not
taxed at all at the state level here in
New Hampshire they're subject only to a
minimal Federal excise tax of 40.26
cents per cigar for a product which
typically sells for five or ten dollars
or
even uh more than that sometimes much
more than that so
and uh
so what this bill does it eliminates the
legal distincts in the rsas between
premium cigars and other cigars so it
deletes the definition of Premium cigar
from rsa78-1 the least two other
references in RSA 78 which was totally
recodified in 2020 and actually one of
the reasons this is a perennial bill but
one of the reasons I haven't
bother to do it in a couple of
legislative Seasons um
well aside from the fact that uh uh
aside from the fact that so far it
hasn't gone far but the committee is
certainly free to change his mind this
time around
um also
um just in 20 and 21 things were kind of
not really normal so this didn't seem
like
this
seemed like just didn't seem like uh I
guess I wanted to limit the number of
bills I was introducing the amount of
Burden they put in the legislative
process but this year I went ahead and
put it in and here I am again so the net
effect of that change
has that changed the leading the
specific uh definition of premium cigars
is that all uh it'll be taxed the same
rate as all other cigars and 60 tobacco
products a rate of 65.03 percent of the
wholesale price and that's 65 percent of
the wholesale price not the retail price
from I've seen premium cigars like most
other consumer goods are marked up about
100 when when retailed and uh
and then backing up a little bit the
history tobacco rate tax rate changes
and little indicates that demand for
tobacco is relatively price inelastic
when the price goes up for whatever
reason demand goes down uh just a little
so my opinion is HB 510 will lead to
well
a lot more tax tobacco tax revenue or
actually it's probably going to be in
the order of about a million dollars so
I guess we can debate whether or not
that's a lot of money
um
I love the little this less tobacco
consumption and those are both desirable
results and uh
I see a couple of the opponents of bills
I remember the the last four hearings
we've had on them and uh
and they claim it would drive to State
cigar buyers out of business because the
cigarfishing nados are all supposedly
all switched to buying cigars online
but there are plenty of cigar bars and
cigar stores in other states which do
packs uh premium Cigars Cigars
product appeals to the census Alicia
from Aficionado I'm kind of I mean I
don't mind smelling occasionally I'm not
really in that category but you know you
can't feel taste or smell the cigars on
the website or a catalog they're also
much more enjoyable when shared with
other cigar aficionados I
parenthetically I've noticed looking at
the websites of various uh cigar
retailers in New Hampshire they all
really a lot of them play up the uh
relation the idea that you can perform a
relationship with the staffs to talk
about the personalities of the staffs
even the people who make them um so you
know especially
there's a gentleman there's a gentleman
here who's going to come in and disagree
with everything I say but uh his his
website uh talks all about himself and
his employers and certainly uh I guess
if you like cigars they're probably fun
people to buy cigars from so and it's a
so it's a very social aspect to a cigar
smoking and they're expensive and
unhealthy maybe not as unhealthy as
cigarettes but they're still not good or
vaping but they're still not as good for
you so
my opinion my take on it is that like
yeah cigar fishing out of those they
avoid avoiding taxes and getting a good
bargain like everyone else but even the
absence of a state line first of all if
you're really bottom line oriented
person if not paying taxes if saving
money is what you really care about
that's
really not the product for you cigar
smoking is not really the bad habit the
or the hobby whatever we want to call it
for you so it's a
and um so actually my opinion is
probably my opinion is the market will
be relatively unaffected if we impose
attacks on them um whether or not
specific language screen this tax
exemption was added to the rsas in 2009
the first year I was in the legislature
as part of the Budget Trailer Bill and
frankly
I'm not quite sure what the rationale
for the for the exemption was it may
just I think it's just one of those
things that gets put in during the
budget process and
we're not quite sure sometimes you're
not quite sure where these things come
from it does hearken back to the days
when New Hampshire was a major
manufacturer of cigars one of the
actually the biggest most famous cigar
factories in the USA was the RG
Sullivan's
7-20-4 factory located in the heart of
downtown Manchester the building is
still standing it still has the RG
Sullivan cigar sign on it um
that area ended
well at some point in the middle of the
last century probably like really almost
100 100 years ago so uh
fire as you can tell there's no cigars
manufactured here in the in the uh New
Hampshire there's a fairly limited
number of cigar bars and cigar stores
um
it's hard some of them are near the
border but uh some of them are some
distance from the border and of course
the whole population of New Hampshire is
concentrated along the border with
Massachusetts I think they're all
located
just judging from where they're located
and so forth they're not just getting
people coming across from Massachusetts
to flee the uh cigar tax down there and
um as I said their cigar bars and cigar
in in Massachusetts
um
and uh and actually I've supported some
bills which would make it easier for
garbars to do business like you know we
constantly there's very things like
there's hookah bars which are licensed
cigar bars which mostly sell uh
non-cigar products and we occasionally
think about wet food and drink they can
sell so I'm not necessary this doesn't
affect any of those but I'm not
necessarily against those businesses I
just think uh
I just think these cigars should be
taxed at the same rate of other tobacco
products and I'm uh obviously not
opposed to high tobacco taxes and um
so I'm confident so I'm confident the
cigar industry in New Hampshire will
it'll it'll rebound from the imposition
of this tax I'm frankly
I mean it's frankly I'm not sure if
it'll make much difference at all to
most of the cigar smokers who are
especially the ones who are coming in to
enjoy it and social social setting so
that's uh I certainly don't think
everything is going to be driven online
um something that should Matt do is we
do have like several cigar retailers who
do a good online business so I don't
think uh I don't think this bill would
it would have would affect that
um
that element of the industry to
adversely because at least in theory the
buyers of the cars as I understand it
have to pay the tax in the state where
the cigars are delivered to so they're
not at least in theory they're not
avoiding these cigar tax and uh
and you can certainly I mean you could
certainly I certainly view that as a
friendly Amendment if you wanted to like
clarify that we're not taxing cigars
that are shipped out of state but um so
and I should also
foreign
manufactured in New Hampshire but the
two places I two companies I found who
are manufacturing their own cigars both
actually have their plants in Central
America one in Honduras and one in
Nicaragua so they're not uh they're not
producing the uh they're not producing
uh the cigars here in New Hampshire
anyway and one
one last digression here which is the
Archie Sullivan company he was
uh I think his name was Robert G
Sullivan he was famous for making one of
the best 10th Cent cigars which I think
when you account for inflation would put
those cigars back in the premium premium
Market but
so that's that's my bill it's been
around the block a few times and uh
maybe this time
maybe uh maybe this time it'll actually
pass and certainly I mean certainly if I
didn't introduce it the chances were
being passed are zero so I would I guess
I'd be happy to take any questions looks
like there may be some representative
Platt has a question yes thank you why
do you care is it the million dollars
you think it might raise or health
effects or what
well it started out I was uh I was more
interested in the e-cigarette and vaping
tax which those were also like not being
taxed as the same rate of the tobacco
products that's luckily uh been kind of
a
that that's been uh that's that's been a
kind of a resolve but there's still this
thing with the cigars I'm not sure why
the cheap cigars should be taxed and
then the expensive one should not be
taxed if anything it would make more
sense to do it the other way around but
um so it's just uh
you know just and it's just it's just
you know it's not really enough to
balance the budget Budget on but it just
seemed like uh it just seemed like a uh
just seemed like a discrepancy like an
oddity in the law of that really served
no discernible purpose at least no
discernible purpose of anyone who's not
in the premium cigar business so thanks
representative Elber
thank you madam chair uh representative
Horrigan
um do you have a sense of what
percentage of all tobacco sales uh is
made up of premium cigars well it's
fairly small it's addressed in the
the frisco note they have they've
captured some of the sales so they they
the state knows about all
sales of premium cigars that are done
through wholesalers who also sell
alcohol and or taxable tobacco products
which would that's what they call other
tobacco products which I guess is mostly
snuff and rolling tobacco and then
cigarettes and also
little cigars which are basically
cigarettes wrapped in brown paper that
uh with uh
it was maybe like a more different
tobacco than you'd use in a cigarette so
they do capture those and uh the figures
there in your fiscal note and ever
memorize the exact number but
assuming this is the right bill it is
um so you know the wholesale value of
premium cigars sold through license
wholesalers once you sell other products
you need a license for is one million
549 and then there's some unknown amount
which are
wholesalers who deal only in premium
cigars and I'm not uh
at least some of the some of the tobacco
pretty much cigar retailers they've
looked and seem to also be selling other
products there and some aren't but so
it's a
and if you if you if you do the math and
assume no effect whatsoever on demand
they came up with a gain of 967 thousand
dollars I'm sure there'd be some
reduction in demand but then there's
also like all the uh
non-licensed wholesalers you're selling
premium cigars that's where I figure
it's about a million dollars more you
know
just doing a very rough pack of the
envelope calculation representative Almy
has a question
thank you were you aware that on the
only reason that we know how much
tobacco gets sold cigarettes get sold in
this state is because of the tobacco of
settlement
and that there is a requirement in the
tobacco settlement that the on
the sellers
uh send lists of who has bought from out
of their state
to the state where they are buying
I was not not aware of it in the great
detail that you are but uh yes I'm I'm
I'm sure you're right and I'm not
disputing and that does not include
cigars
that uh thank you yes in terms of
other questions
seeing none thank you for oh I apologize
that you are representative orrs
thank you for taking my question Madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question representative so I'm looking
at the health statistic you've provided
it seems to be very low risk product and
I'm looking at all the times you
submitted the bill it looks like you've
taken a pretty good butt whooping on
that uh we just heard from the gaming
Commission
that we are losing a lot of charitable
money to Massachusetts because of the
way we set fees and that kind of thing
I mean it doesn't sound like you've done
your homework in terms of what was just
representative I'll stop you there this
is a question not questioning any
motives we're actually questioning the
factual stuff in the bill I'm such a
rookie
yeah so we don't we have we never
question motives or that kind of thing
uh but if you have a technical question
about the intent of the bill please ask
that question thank you thank you guys
I'm gonna get there eventually I guess
so I noticed that most of the cigar bars
or whatever they're called are along the
border so my concern is that we're going
to lose this business to Massachusetts
do you have you done any studies at all
to determine whether or not we are I
mean you had an opinion yet but have you
actually done any studies well the the
anecdote we heard and I think the
gentleman I heard the anecdote from is
probably going to get up and testify
after me sort of his version of the
story is that there's one well-known
cigar
retailer and mail order retailer here
who
um he'd been fighting with state of
Massachusetts over their tax and then he
picked up and moved the whole business
to New Hampshire and I guess actually
turns out the locations he sold his
locations in Massachusetts and I don't
see any evidence that they stopped
operating as cigar buyers but uh I mean
people there may be some I will say
we're
and this is these are subjects for other
bills but uh we are way behind
Massachusetts well we're extremely
behind in cannabis we have no legal
cannabis sales whatsoever in New
Hampshire whereas Massachusetts has a
thriving cannabis industry and um
in terms of gaming you know they're
they're ahead of us too you know they
have uh they have that nice beautiful
new Wind Casino in Everett can we
refocus this conversation on premium
cigars yeah exactly thank you
um I'm not too con I'm not too concerned
I mean uh I'm not sure if there's I
think I'm not sure if there's much of a
price War over the Border as people
people think and uh okay I mean if they
if they lower their if we raise them
they lower their price there may be some
effect but uh I don't haven't haven't
studied in the detail I mean what I
heard from the industry of course is
that if we put a tax in this the whole
new hampshire-based industry will
evaporate and that's inconsistent with
what I've seen going on in Massachusetts
thank you very much okay the chair will
recognize Curtis Berry from
representing the cigar Association of
New Hampshire
thank you madam chair
um and good afternoon members of the
committee uh I'll apologize to those
members of the committee that have been
here for a while because this is
repetitive we've heard it all before as
representative Horrigan mentioned
representative I will address your
question as part of my testimony and I
think the response that was anticipated
by the sponsor is going to be quite
different than than what we have uh to
give as an example in reality
um first of all I want to address the
cigar bar issue just to set the stage
and and explain or remind about how the
statute Works relative to cigar bars
um many of the cigar retailers do not
have also a cigar bar license some of
them do among our group there are
probably I think five Cigar Bar licenses
of the 13 or 14 or so maybe more now
locations that I'm here on behalf of
but the statute requires 60 percent of
your Revenue to come from the sales of
cigars and cigar related products
which means if you don't have the cigar
store the cigar bar goes away by Statute
full stop
um
so to the bill directly
um in in I'll apologize again uh
representative almi reminded me I left
you a packet but I did not put my
business card attached to the packet it
was paper clipped in in the top sheet
looked like this it is a copy of the
statute so what you don't see in the
bill is introduced is very pertinent
this is how the statute defines premium
cigar
and one piece that I'll draw your
attention to is
um
the first one is made entirely by hand
of all natural tobacco leaf
so it's not like other tobacco products
where there are flavorings chemicals Etc
this is 100 leaf tobacco no stems or
anything
um
that's important for context now there
are three states New Hampshire being one
of them that does not tax what is
defined as premium cigars the other two
of Florida
and Pennsylvania those two states have a
very heavy presence of cigar
manufacturers there so their influence
is felt but New Hampshire also has
created an industry that sells premium
cigars
um in on the next page in in the packet
which was the map that was referred to
earlier there are a number of locations
with stores that are affiliated with our
organization and as you can see many of
them are along the southern border or
along I-93 that is not by accident
the sales of premium cigars I imagine
much like the per capita beer sales in
the state are not to New Hampshire's
residents because New Hampshire
residents are
smoke cigars heavier than the rest of
the nation
a premium cigar if stored correctly will
last a very long time which means the
ability to sell to out-of-state
customers who come here occasionally
they can load up put it in a humidor
store it and enjoy it later on
so what you see is by Design
now
um one thing about the association I'd
like you to keep in mind relative to
these locations is we
estimate over a hundred employees total
among these these retailers so it's a a
small but important part of the economy
um
the speculation or the assertion that
stores will not close if you pass the
tax is refuted by an actual example and
the truth is Mr Dave Garofalo with me
today
uh owns three locations Seabrook Nashua
and Salem
uh had several stores in Massachusetts
before in the mid 90s and he did fight
the tax down there that is true and when
the state of Massachusetts decided to
tax premium cigars he closed up shop and
moved to New Hampshire and the truth is
that at that time before the tax there
were 30 some odd cigar stores in the
Greater Boston area today
there's one
one store
that is an actual result of their tax
so what happens when you pass the tax in
New Hampshire
a the vast majority of sales come from
out of state residents B those residents
have access to Cigars over the Internet
also mentioned by the sponsor so if
you're paying the tax the cost is the
same are you going to enjoy the
convenience of the internet or continue
to buy in New Hampshire we assert the
same result will happen in New Hampshire
the stores will close
the cigar bars will close you will not
get the alcohol sales from cigar bars
you will not get the business taxes the
state receives from the stores that will
close that the state enjoys now to
whatever extent it is that is not
speculation that's the experience and
what the cigar store owners tell me will
be the result
um
it's also already been referenced but
the um
the third document that I've given you
is a series of data points on cigar
smoking and this comes from as the the
notes indicate National Institutes of
Health FDA this is not the cigar
industry one important piece that I know
is important to some on the committee on
the left column uh indicated by a little
birthday cake icon the average age of an
individual's first premium cigar is 30
years old
compared to younger age for cigarettes
so we're not talking about youth access
the last page again already been
referred to as I wanted to provide you
with the legislative history for this
section of the tobacco tax statute
um and again I was going to point out
but it's already been pointed out
several times the committee has seen
this provision before and I certainly
hope that the committee's committee sees
fit to dispose of this bill as previous
legislatures have
um
on the note on the fiscal note
it's awful hard awfully hard to
determine
um because we may not know all of the
sales and
I'm not aware that dra can
score a fiscal note if you will
dynamically in other words they don't
anticipate what percentage of the New
Hampshire sales go away we believe there
will be virtually no Revenue increase if
this bill is passed because the sales in
large part will go away
um
so
I'll close with
um an analogy if you will
um because it's been raised about taxing
the other tobacco products
the way I look at it is calling a
premium cigar the same as a cigarette
for example
would be the same as calling the filet
mignon the same as a hot dog
we're talking about 100 percent leaf
tobacco we're talking about 100 beef
versus the other two which have many
other ingredients
in a completely different product
so we don't think there's additional
Revenue you'll lose the revenue that
you're getting from the existing
businesses
the science backs up our position uh so
we don't see any compelling reason to uh
to pass the bill we see a lot of reasons
to keep the statute the way it is
myself and Mr Garofalo happy to answer
representative Almy has a question
thank you
um I actually lived in a cigar producing
very small very poor town in Brazil
the Cuban expatriates had created it
hand wrapped is not something you're
going to be able to produce economically
in the United States
uh
so these are all imported and could you
tell me I believe that there are huge
numbers of small tobacco grower Growers
still producing cigars around the world
and sending them to the United States
among other places
Madam chair if it's okay I'd like to
defer to one of the foremost cigar uh
most knowledgeable people about cigars
that I've ever met Mr Garofalo if that's
okay yes
um because there does seem to be a
problem with
um finding the Distributors that are
going to be paying the tax if they were
taxed
yeah that part I couldn't speak to I
don't think either one of us could that
maybe it would rely you to rely upon dra
for for their insight
and and by the way there are two
companies based in New Hampshire
um that are cigar manufacturers
obviously don't actually produce them
here
um Kurt Kendall with twins uh smoke shop
has resurrected that 724 brand which we
see on the building in Manchester at one
time the world's largest manufacturer of
cigars and there's another New Hampshire
native uh who has created a company
who's a former executive for a
manufacturer
um retired from the the large company
and created a company he calls Dunbarton
tobacco and Trust he lives in Dunbarton
and sells Nationwide as well produces
elsewhere but a fairly successful
representative Malloy
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question I think the
information you have on on uh
it is very good I appreciate the
statistics uh one and maybe it's in here
somewhere but if you were to draw a
trend line of cigar usage per capita
over the last 20 25 years what would
that trend line look like up down
sideways per capita usage however you
measure it it's just a point of
information for me sure that's all
understood it may I defer that one as
well
absolutely Mr Garofalo if you share to
join us um and then we just need you to
fill out a pink card Curtis you can show
them how to do that that'd be great
welcome
um I'd say the past 20 years have been
pretty flat
um as far as sales were there was a boom
in the early 1990s
um that boosted it up a little bit and
since then it's been pretty flat for uh
other questions Representatives ORS
thank you madam chair and thanks for
taking my question so are either of you
aware that cigars are still hand rolled
in Saint Augustine Florida because I've
been there and I'm wondering if you knew
that yes yeah uh Tampa is is a place
where cigars are still rolled um JC
Newman cigar Factory the last major size
Factory that's there little places for
um you know show basically with Taurus
or something would see it but for for me
for a major consumption uh Tampa seems
to be the last place left as far as
growing tobacco uh the Connecticut River
Valley including Massachusetts
Pennsylvania
Connecticut obviously
um is is a bed of uh growing and now uh
Florida actually brought it back after
150 years uh the growing tobacco down in
Florida now too we're talking uh tobacco
for cigars which is a actually a
different product than a tobacco for
anything else including cigarettes
thank you
representative Ames
hi if you know
what is the rule for online taxation by
other states
of uh cigars
the tax is for the state that
um
it collects it as the the products being
sold so this States take Massachusetts
for instance the man that's still
surviving when I left Massachusetts uh
is L.J Peretti in Boston he's still
there there were 30 of us when I left
he's the last one that's standing uh the
bulk of his business is why he's even
surviving the one person that's
surviving is the bulk of his business is
sold online
and he sells that in a tax state which
is a 40 tax state uh but when he sells
it online it's zero tax
so the majority of consumers as Curtis
said
um if there is tax within the state
they'll choose to buy it in another
state
um
and um you know they'll uh not have to
pay the tax as as it would be
um there's uh by the way if if this tax
was to happen this would go from one of
three lowest tax states to the highest
the the number one highest right now is
New York it's 75 percent this would be
number two uh in all the United States
of the highest tax I left Massachusetts
at 12 tax it was enough that would bury
me because the the margins are not there
like he said the margins can be maybe 30
percent when it comes to selling a box
of cigars and at 12 disadvantage of that
and adding sales tax again Massachusetts
compounding federal tax with State Tax
with sales tax uh I knew I wasn't going
to be able to survive and I left and I
was basically laughed at for leaving
because I was probably the number one
guy in Boston at the time when I left
but I knew that I would not be able to
survive and nor would these people that
were other retailers that said we'll be
okay they're all gone
and the same thing will happen in New
Hampshire
that will be gone and you know possibly
going to one of those other states and
selling within the state of New
Hampshire which there was no online
sales when I left in 1995. now it's a
whole different game that you know just
goes somewhere else and just sell into
the state Mass New Hampshire will get
none of the tax uh money because it
won't add up to anything that will go in
and also there'll be a hundred people
plus lose their job in the businesses
will go away there is no upsell to it uh
because of the way tax goes from state
to state when it comes to Tobacco just
to clarify follow-up yep I'm sorry
um just to be sure I understand so the
the business that remains in
Massachusetts if it's
sells into Mass to a consumer or a place
in Massachusetts it's it's Massachusetts
tax right if if they sell out of
Massachusetts
zero tax they'll collect nothing
out of state right out of state to uh
New Hampshire if the tax happen here in
New Hampshire I could sell to
Massachusetts and give no tax to New
Hampshire right right no I think I
understood okay representative
my question good answer with that last
Exchange
yes representative elberger yes
thank you madam chair and thank you both
for taking my questions I'm looking at
the fact sheet that you gave us and it
points out as you mentioned that the uh
typical age for a cigar a premium cigar
smoker is higher than for cigarettes and
you also point out that
um
the typical premium scar smoker is
better educated perhaps than the general
population
um I wonder if we can infer from that
that the typical premium cigar smoker
also has more disposable income
then
I guess my sense is to respond it's a
fair
inference
um because it's true as representative
Horrigan said premium cigars are not
inexpensive so
that said you know if somebody I think
you'll find and these folks will tell
you
um that cigar premium cigar smoking is
very seasonal another demonstration that
it's not addictive people will smoke
more often when they're Outdoors to
mowing the lawn they're on the boat
playing on the golf course
um so you know cigar smoking can be
occasional as well
um so there may be some folks that are
just a few times a year and there are
going to be some folks that are weekly
uh thank you
um you mentioned that hot dogs and filet
mignon are
beef
but
um they're not the same product but
they're still taxed at the same rate if
you go to a restaurant and buy a hot dog
and you buy filet mignon your text the
same rate correct they are observation
thank you
thank you madam chair
representative spilsbury thank you madam
chair
um I'm just this question is for Mr
Garofalo
uh I'm curious without putting any
numbers on it what taxes does your
business pay or do you pay for your
business activities in the state of New
Hampshire
uh knock on wood I've been doing this
for 38 years I started in the cigar
business uh 38 years ago 1985 we paid
business profits to I don't know what
the numbers are but we're successful and
um we are one of the largest cigar
retailers in the world not just the
United States in the world uh thank you
to New Hampshire for the New Hampshire
Advantage which certainly did that I was
a a good retailer in Massachusetts
and then as taxes around us happen
um I became one of the top retailers in
the world so uh this is certainly profit
I pay what I'm supposed to pay whatever
that number is and if I knew it off the
top of my head I would be happy to share
it to you proudly share it with you it's
successful we're certainly not taking a
loss even through covid
um you know I I was not able to show a
quarter the that we didn't make profit
on so I couldn't collect because we made
profit all the time and as Curtis said
um it is a product of convenience of
when you have time to enjoy it our
business drops
um probably about 80 percent in the
winter months so January February March
not not very good at all and and there I
would show you that no we're not very
profitable at all we may actually have a
loss when the weather gets good uh
business gets really good during covid
people had time to enjoy cigars in our
business actually took a bump up all of
a sudden where uh in most cases a lot of
places were hurting in business and we
ended up doing very well because people
had time for it when people went back to
work we do have a non-addictive product
the nicotine level and the cigar is
between one and three percent when you
take other Tibet other products period a
tomato is five percent nicotine eggplant
is eight percent nicotine a cigar is one
to three percent nicotine it's very very
small it goes to a process to actually
delete that to happen it's just a
natural byproduct of a Nightshade grown
product which is a tomato an eggplant
and uh there's a little bit in it but
not enough to make people want to smoke
outdoors in the cold not want to do it
when they're not comfortable to to do it
when price has an issue to it they just
stop you know we're looking at the
economy right now as the Slowdown
happens
it happened in 2007 and we were the
first to see the Slowdown happen because
nobody needs my product
and the more you make it difficult to
people to uh obtain it or pay extra for
it they check out so I I feel like the
taxation I know the taxation uh ended up
hurting uh friends below us here in
Massachusetts uh if I may yeah follow up
so that I think that was very uh
interesting answer in addition to the
business profits tax does your business
pay a variety of other taxes
if every every tax we're supposed to pay
meals and rum business Enterprise
absolutely liquor
well indirectly Through The Gruffalo
does not have a cigar bar license in any
of his does not have an operating cigar
bar at any of his three uh locations
okay so you're just a retail sales
operation not one of the cigar bars
okay very good thank you representative
Plitt I just wanted to thank you I'm
representative orrs
thank you madam chair and stay away from
me rep plot uh so thank you for taking
my question so you're telling us that
you can kind of see which way the
economy is going
by your cigar sale so where is the
economy going in 2023 yes I absolutely
can and and when that happened in 2007 a
lot of people thought that happened in
2008 and I I was a barometer for the
first thing that would somebody would
give up and it became literally lighting
a ten dollar bill on fire uh is the
business that I'm in and I saw it first
and said oh here's what's happening and
then friends and other businesses would
see it like restaurants would see it
next uh entertainment would see it as it
as it went down here we are in a bad
first quarter of the Year anyway but
business is down q1 to q1 last year so
I'd say the economy is is affecting us
as we see it now
thank you I think we had a question over
here representative leapley did I miss
you yes I did have a question thank you
thank you for taking my question this
has been very interesting
um
my question is because it it does when
you read the bill it's weird that
premium cigars are this special thing
that is exempt from this tax and it it
is kind of a like playing field fairness
question for me I'm wondering if there
is a tax amount that would seem fair to
you so I'll tell you how this this began
um and um it was brought up that there's
some
cigars to call themselves cigars little
cigars and really what they are is
cigarettes wrapped in brown paper and
they call themselves cigars and they
were never cigars and they did that
because there was an exemption on all
cigars as taxed differently so because
these people did this we now had to
separate what a cigar is that is not a
today to this day it's called a little
cigar it's a cigarette with brown paper
instead of white paper and then it
became the next category would end up
doing a thing called something else a
cigar the same thing happened with pipe
tobacco pipe tobacco within the state is
actually very very high tax you collect
nothing on it because it's so used so
little but it was the cigarette
companies that used roll your own
cigarettes and started calling it pipe
tobacco and then the government came in
and said I see what you're doing now
we're going to tax pipe tobacco at 68
and then nobody buys pipe tobacco in the
state of New Hampshire nobody
it's it's if you figure out the money
that it adds up to it adds up to nothing
because they buy it all online I used to
sell an awful lot of pipe tobacco but at
68 I don't sell to pipe tobacco anymore
not only do it does it add up to
anything I don't even carry it anymore
because nobody will buy it
if you tax cigars at 68 I will not
operate in the state of New Hampshire
period I left at 15 12. I left at 12
it just will not end up happening
because we have the opportunity my
customers have the opportunity to buy it
from someone else somewhere else
follow-up
so is there a tax rate that you think
would be fair to tax premiums we're at
the perfect tax rate right now thank you
and one of those three states and it is
the New Hampshire Advantage my customers
don't drive up from multiple States as I
told you as I proudly say uh we sell an
awful lot of cigars
and when they do come up they buy
lottery tickets they buy the liquor in
the liquor stores they use the
restaurants they maybe stay at the
hotels they don't use the the roads they
don't use the police they don't use the
fire department they drop all their
money off to everything and then they
leave
what better what better customer in the
world would you want than this and these
people have money yes it is a disposable
income type of person and some of these
people have a lot of money to drop lots
of money off in the State uh don't let
them go away because there's nothing but
negative that's going to happen they're
going to not come anymore and drop it
off and you will collect no money just
ask Massachusetts they had the same
thing that they thought they were going
to make a few million dollars in
Massachusetts in 1995 when they added
the tax that was at 12 percent they went
to 15 they went to 20 they went to 30
they went to 40 and they're still
chasing this dream of three million
dollars there's one guy left the guy
doesn't do 3 million in sales you can
tax him a ten thousand percent it can't
add up to any money that ends up
happening it's just bad business
um and um those poor retailers that had
to figure out something else after the
fact and knock on wood I was one that
actually packed my bags and left but uh
nobody else followed they stayed they
stayed and went down with the ship uh if
this was to happen I'm not I'm going to
do the same exact thing I'm not going to
go down with the ship I'm just going to
close shop and maybe go to Florida it's
warm there it's you know Cigar City
perhaps yeah representative Olney has a
question
I'm not sure I need to ask it of you but
um can you visualize any way that oh can
you visual can you tell us the
impediments to us collecting tax on a
product which has gone mostly online
well that's another thing of collecting
the tax so and somebody would have to do
it I've asked a question many times of
the non
um premium cigar how much is really
coming in on non-premium cigars and I've
asked it year after year and and they
have no calculation to it so if it's
very minuscule the tax you're collecting
on pipe tobacco at 68 it's it's
virtually nothing and how much you're
getting on non-premium cigars it it's
virtually nothing and I could build my
business even more if you would not tax
that make that go away too because
you're collecting nothing for it and
you're just hurting the retailers that
are in here so I would go as far as to
you know instead of play defensive here
play offensive and say will you please
take that other tax off that is just
sitting there making you no money and
hurting the the people of New Hampshire
at the same time we could uh do better
if we could make that go away as opposed
to try to uh what does it cost you to
collect the tax
there's uh people that's job is trying
to figure that out and neglect it it may
be worth less you may be spending more
money trying to collect this little
amount of money
um then you then it's worth and I would
even go on to say that Massachusetts
trying to collect this little 40 percent
of this little amount that is happening
within that state is probably not worth
worth their wild it certainly isn't
three million dollars or one million
dollars
representative did I see your hand over
there
okay yes
dead just for
application purposes and I was there
when this went through so but when
you're talking about the little cigar
the cigarillo type thing I seem to
recall some testimony regarding its
construction compared to that of a
premium cigar where premium cigars is a
leaf rolled preferably from Connecticut
because they make the best uh wrapper
and then material from whichever one of
the various different you know places
that makes them Express tobacco
but if I remember your testimony at that
time
you were talking about scrapings and
floor sweepings and bits and pieces and
stuff going into the cigarillo or the
little cigar which
is one of the reasons for the difference
is shop tobacco which is how a cigarette
is made I mean they can make a thousands
and thousands of cigarettes in a minute
where a cigar a pair of two people
making cigars make 300 per day
two people make three hundred cigars per
day where the machine makes 300 a second
of making these cigarettes whether they
use brown paper or white paper that
doesn't matter one other thing that came
up back in those days was the
um other cigars that you may see in a
convenience store
and those were flavored cigars that if
you tip them upside down all the tobacco
comes out what why would that end up
happening it's little pieces of tobacco
that's inside of this quote cigar and
all this was was the wrapper that was
used and then it was to be refilled with
marijuana and this was uh um just
another way of of rolling as a
not a uh I can't think of what that's
called the rolling paper I guess that
people would
um put marijuana in or they would use a
leaf which was this cigar that you
poured out and I believe we had an
example uh representative Almy I think
you brought the products in
if you remember back then I brought a
lot of products in there was nothing
there was banana flavor chocolate flavor
orange flavor and very little low levels
of tobacco because it was meant it
called itself a cigar and it was not a
cigar so what we tried to do is say this
when I got in the business in 1985 all
they wore was cigars and then these
companies came in and started making
believe their product was a cigar and
it's not so we we were the first state
in the country to actually Define what a
cigar was just to say these other things
are not
and that gave us the exemption of it the
the exemption is cigars the other things
if you say why aren't the other cigars
or the inexpensive cigars because
they're not cigars I know what a cigar
is and what a cigar isn't those are not
cigars and they're not even pretending
to be it's just they're pretending in
writing to be as that roll your own
cigarette it's not pipe tobacco you
cannot smoke it in a pipe it's made for
roll your own cigarettes but with tax
again in the state it's 68 percent
because they call it that but it is
different it could there could be maybe
a definition of what pipe tobacco is
because these other people that do this
kind of ruin it for the entire industry
making believe that their product is
different
representative Oliver
he said with trepidation
are you telling me that zigzags are used
for something other than tobacco yes yes
okay any serious questions
representative roachford
thank you madam chair I'm just
trying to wrap my head around because I
just in full disclosure we have a
premium cigar store in my town I've
never been into it I wouldn't know
a good cigar from a bad cigar
um
but uh I I look at the business that
they're doing in my town we're a Border
Town bordering Vermont I go up 19 miles
north to the town of Lancaster where we
have a cigar bar there uh where people
come from all around to to to drink and
to to smoke cigars
I I'm just trying to understand this and
bear with me here and I will get to a
question
um
okay I look at you know efforts to tax
flavored cigarettes or flavored tobacco
in an effort to get kids off of it but
you said this isn't an addictive issue
it's not a health concern or is it a
children children aren't interested
children aren't in our children aren't
interested so we can check that off the
Box
am I missing something here I just think
that this is a this bill here is a
solution
looking for a problem
it might I mean I I don't see that this
is the pressing issue New Hampshire has
to solve today 100
all right that's our assessment as well
any other questions
[Music]
there's a question representative Almy
I just like to make a statement i've
smoked my first and last cigar at the
age of eight with my cousin we stole it
from our grandfather and neither of us
ever smoked again
it did it it did its duty to stop you
for that no childhood like that
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you for coming and oh sir don't
forget to fill out the pink card thank
you so much okay and we have Keane Wong
here from the dra who can probably
foreign
members of the committee my name is Kim
Ming Wong tax policy Council of the
Department of Revenue the department
does not have a position on this bill we
did prepare a fiscal note on the bill
and
um this bill as described by the sponsor
is uh proposing to tax the premium
cigars under the tobacco tax statute
when we were preparing the fiscal note
it wasn't clear to us the tax rate that
was going to be used on the cigars so
when we prepared this fiscal note we
assumed that it is taxed as an other
tobacco product which is at 65.03
um preparing this fiscal note we used as
explained in previous testimony there is
um no complete information uh for us to
calculate the total fiscal impact if uh
if this bill were to pass however we did
try to get as much information as
possible through looking at the returns
that's been submitted so wholesalers do
submit a return to us on a monthly basis
wholesalers who sell other tobacco
products and within that return that
it's called a form dp151 within that
return the wholesalers do report
the amount of premium cigars that sold
in New Hampshire
and bear in mind this is only for the
wholesalers who do sell other tobacco
products and they are licensed in New
Hampshire
so wholesalers that only sell premium
cigars will not be captured in this
population of our calculation
and within our calculation we've
determined that it uh that the wholesale
price of premium cigars that were sold
in New Hampshire from fiscal year 22 was
about 1.4 million dollars and applying
the 65.03 percent will give us 967
thousand dollars of Revenue
and as mentioned in previous testimony
the dra does not have the capability of
determining whether the uh an increase
or imposition of this tax would result
in a loss in sale or an increase in sale
we do not have that capability we're
only able to report on what available
representative Albany
thank you on
we
assumed that a number of the people who
were buying on
in place are going to be buying online
do you have any way to find those people
I I not to my knowledge that we're able
to determine whether the um they're
buying online or buy at the store most
likely if they're buying online
any purchases that's done online the
consumer will be the ones who are
reporting the taxes versus if they're
buying at the store the uh the host the
wholesaler will have to report that tax
so that that probably would be the only
way we could determine that
thank you and
for the case of cigarettes on
the
the on cigarette the tobacco settlement
includes fibbing on everybody who bought
tobacco bought cigarettes online from
the participating manufacturers that is
and you go after them
but there is no such mechanism I think
for
for any other product yeah I I believe
not since if it's not covered under the
thank you madam chair
uh
your fiscal note calculations are based
on a static analysis and therefore
they're predicated on current sales
volume that is correct do you imagine
that the imposition of a 65 percent
wholesale tax
would dampen sales volume and therefore
reduce the anticipated Revenue
without being able to quantify it does
that seem likely
we we would not be able to predict
consumer Behavior so it's we would not
thank you point made
okay any other questions
thank you very much for coming thank you
I don't have any more pink cards is
there anyone else here who would like to
seeing none we will close the public
hearing
we will now open the public hearing on
House Bill 568.
uh we have received an email message I
hope everyone on the committee received
it
um from the prime sponsor who said he
did not want to move forward with this
bill
I believe it still would be in order for
someone to introduce it and then we
could conclude the public hearing uh
representative fellows would you care to
the bill before us today is House Bill
568 relative to assessing all estate
adequate education and local Education
costs through the State education
warrant
and because I am not the sponsor I don't
have any testimony to offer about this
bill
thank you for so much for introducing
the bill and let me just read the email
that we received from the prime sponsor
uh representative Sanborn uh yes I guess
it was sent to me and I hopefully
forwarded it to everyone else I have
decided not to follow through with House
Bill 568 FN relative to assessing All
State adequate education and local
Education costs through the State
education warrant I would like to
withdraw it the bill is not written the
way I intended and the timing is not
right for amending
uh please advise me if there's anything
else I need to do to vacate the bill so
the gentleman requested the bill to be
vacated but it was too late to be
vacated per the house clerk because it
already been scheduled for public
hearing here so that's why we've opened
the public hearing uh is there anyone in
the audience here to testify on House
anyone from the committee have anything
to say yes representative am I correct
that if uh with a situation like this if
the minority leader and the chair agree
we could exec immediately and uh dispose
of it I believe uh that is the new house
rule that we've adopted
um we have not discussed this at all so
I wouldn't want to presume anything but
we can certainly close the public
hearing
and we can discuss whether an immediate
exec session would be an order so with
that I will close a public hearing on
so uh this is a public work session of
the entire house Ways and Means
Committee and we are discussing House
Bill 568 as well as a recently passed
house rule that would allow us to
immediately go into an executive session
on a bill if we have agreement uh
between the chair the members of the
committee and the ranking member of the
committee to exec a bill that was just
heard that same day
we have a situation here in front of us
with House Bill 568 which the prime
sponsor has asked us not to move forward
with so I believe we have consensus
representative only would you like to
tell us how you feel about exacting this
bill now
I agree
okay so we will now enter the an
executive session on House Bill 568 and
the chair will recognize representative
thank you madam chair I make a motion to
itl
HP 568. do we have a second
representative almie
um
go ahead
uh thank you madam chair so um
discussion is very succinct it's pretty
much what you just said we we actually
have written a written email from the
prime sponsor basically saying he would
like to withdraw the bill so at this
point it makes total sense we're all in
agreement to uh itl
foreign
call the roll on the motion of Ito yes
mad I'm chair
uh representative janigian
well said yes I'm sorry I stumbled
earlier
it's the alcohol
not having heard anything about the bill
yes
representative uh Doucet yes
representative spilsbury yes
representative plaid votes yes represent
Heinz not here
uh representative sodi yes
representative orrs yes
representative yes
representative army yes representative
Ames
he had to leave okay fine uh
yes represent fellows yes representative
Bolton yes representative Elber yes
representative leapley yes
representative Smith yes and the chair
yes okay the vote is 17 uh to zero and
Serena present
so we learned that we can put an itl's
well we can put a bill on consent
calendar with a unanimous vote this one
does have an FN but we can put it on
consent calendar because it's an ideal
motion so we will put on consent unless
anyone objects
and seeing none we will close the
okay thank you for working with me on
that parliamentary and thing
we are done for the day and we will see
you tomorrow at 10 so we can begin the
goodness
let's try let me see if we can we can
I just want to make sure we're doing it
appropriately and I just thought we were
so